morning if you would please uh rise and
join me for the Pledge of
Allegiance flag of the United States of
America and to theic for it stands one
nation under God indivisible with liy
and justice for
all was some kind of break dancing going
on over
there with that I open the public
hearing on Hos Bill 1039 invite the
sponsor to introduce the
bill oh it's one of ours
hi morning folks um for the record I'm
Amanda Balin I'm State Rep from
Manchester board five Hillsboro District
25 um I'll keep it brief we have some
stakeholders here today to speak to this
legislation um this bill allows the
judge to assign an alternative sentence
when they see fit
um an alternative sentence could include
drug treatment job training job
placement financial literacy classes and
so forth stakeholders work together on
this legislation to ensure it only
covers a limited list of crimes which
are
non-violent per the legislation certain
crimes are are exceptions and a judge is
not allowed to assign an alternative
sentence in those cases examples include
assault sexual crimes crimes against
children domestic violence
etc for that reason you'll note that any
any sort of treatment related to these
types of crimes is not listed under the
types of alternative sentencing in the
bill because anyone convicted of that
type of crime wouldn't be eligible for
alternative
sentencing while it was difficult to
establish uh contact with the Coalition
against sexual domestic violence in the
months leading up to um this hearing and
as we were working on the language uh
stakeholders did make a considered
effort to ensure that the coalition's
concerns were incorporated into this
language
um there are for example
are uh exceptions included that we
believe the Coalition would
support making exceptions
um so similar legislation has passed in
other states this bill is modeled off of
Tennessee's uh recent law and uh this
legislation is brought forward in the
spirit of article 18 of the Bill of
Rights in our States Constitution
which states in part that the true
design of all punishments is to reform
mankind um so this legislation is
intended to ensure that our justice
system is uh actively engaged in
reforming as opposed to um simply
limiting because
philosophically when you go to uh when
you are incarcerated your freedom your
Liberty is taken for a period of time um
to punish you
um but if we're just catch and release
Catch and Release what are we achieving
and uh the idea with this legislation is
to ensure that people are funneled into
um systems uh resources experiences that
would help them uh grow and improve as
human beings so that they won't be
incarcerated again happy to take any
questions thank you um
just for I'm I'm interested um did the
does the court already not have the
option to impose these versus um I mean
because we don't have minimum or or
mandatory jail sentences right so can
they not already do this what what what
what makes this necessary the idea here
is to make it very clear that it's the
intent of the the preferred right okay
that when it's appropriate and it's up
to the judge um and in particular um the
use of the word caregiver is present
throughout the bill because we're
specifically looking at people who are
the Breadwinners in their household um
we're thinking like you know talking
about maybe
[Music]
um someone is the only person employed
in their household maybe they have young
children dependent upon them maybe
they're paying child support maybe as in
my case um my elderly mother lives with
me and I care for her and um people in
that type of situation the ripple effect
of incarceration is vast um if I
disappeared one day um even just for a
couple of months the impact on my mom's
quality of life would be severe and um
when you're talking about children if
their only caregiver is gone um those
children will potentially end up in the
system we do have laws in New Hampshire
that would preferentially send them to
maybe grandparents or something but
absent that sort of option um maybe
those children end up in the system um
that's a financial outlay to the state
and the taxpayers um there could be
emotional impacts of losing a parent to
um the prison system that down the road
maybe those people who are impacted end
up part of the uh Criminal Justice
System themselves and not in a great
way um and
similarly if let's say the situation is
like one of two parents uh is the bread
winner ends up
incarcerated uh maybe the other parent
can't really make ends meet without that
other parent there they apply for
benefits their own welfare and all the
while taxpayers are paying to house and
feed the productive parent the bread
winner that um would otherwise be able
to contribute to their household
independently so there's a financial
impact to incarceration if it's if it's
possible to address the behavioral
issues the criminal behavior of that
person um through some kind of program
and the judge agrees that that would be
effective and there's the bill includes
um accountability as well um and the
option for the judge to revert to prison
time if necessary um but if uh the judge
feels it's appropriate there are so many
benefits across um all aspects of life
in New Hampshire from um you know the
impact on the taxpayers long-term impact
on youths who maybe have lost a loved
one to um incarceration and how their
lives could be changed by being able to
grow up with that caregiver in their
life um as opposed to you know the chaos
and Trauma that comes with losing a
loved one in that situation um and then
additionally if we can actually reform
someone instead of Simply limiting their
freedom and their liberties with
incarceration um then we should be
focused on
that thank you very much um forther
questions represent
Muse you have a a pretty exhaustive list
of the of the exceptions uh what I'm
what I'm wondering about are the things
that might be more the the rule in cases
like this so what kind of crimes uh do
you think would be eligible for this
type of
treatment um I think we're talking um PO
for example if someone has a serious
pattern of maybe um speeding you know
maybe not paying their tickets things
like that that's someone who would
benefit from financial literacy classes
um maybe like a defensive driving a more
extensive defensive driving course um
there's a variety of small Petty things
that can pile up over time that could
eventually lead to jail time where it's
more an issue of
someone just having it together um being
able to manage money manage their time
manage their own impulses which can come
down to Simply mental health issues and
that's why uh therapy is part of the
list of um options for how to address
these things uh just with ADHD alone
which so many people in the country in
the world have um impulse control is a
major problem um um and there's
different aspects of ADHD I I have it I
don't think I really have the impulse
control part of it so much compared to
other people um more of the um spaced
out variety of ADHD but um you know
there's that's kind of the issue right
is that as we progress as a society and
we move on from using leeches to give
medical care and we learn more um we
become more scientific we do more
studies we start to learn that there are
different ways to address behavioral
issues um than simply
incarceration thank
you represent Mar thank you Mr
chairman what numbers do you do you have
any numbers on how many people would be
impacted by this because my impression
is that a vast majority if not over 90%
of people who are currently incarcerated
are parents either mother father
caregiver they are so it just seems like
an enormous population would be impacted
and if I might also it's a two-part
question um do you think that sometimes
taking a step out of a lifestyle to
relearn new habits um would be
beneficial as well just like a timeout
thank you for taking my question on the
second part um there's other ways to
step out of Lifestyle besides
incarceration that's the point of
halfway homes um sober homes things like
that um so there are a lot of different
ways that human beings can address
hanging out in the wrong crowd um
otherwise if I thought my teenager was
hanging out with the wrong crowd I'd
just call the Hillsboro County Jail you
know so we have options um and on the
first part it's it's a two um there's
two components here it's not simply
caregiver and it's not simply nonviolent
it's both so it's a non-violent crime
that of which a caregiver is convicted
and that number should should be very
small but for those people and for the
people that depend on them the impact is
significant um but I believe other
stakeholders on this legislation were
looking into getting that kind of data
that was something that we talked about
in our many meetings um I don't have the
data but maybe someone else speaking
today would and if they're here I assume
they don't even have to be asked they'
just bring it
up further qu representative sing sorry
thank you very much this is um a bit of
a followup on representative Reed's
question thank you for taking my
question um so if a parent or a
caregiver needed to be sentenced for
example to a halfway house um away from
their family temporarily to work through
their issues but would still have access
to visiting them and seeing them or
perhaps going to their place of
employment um is that something that is
possible with how this is written just
to so I understand I I don't believe so
however um it is uh likely the
legislation says that the uh that a
judge could assign some other kind of um
resources or
experience um for the convicted person
if the judge finds it appropriate and I
think it's worth considering that um in
addition to incarceration halfway home
sober homes there's also partial
inpatient
hospitalization um that's something that
exists in New Hampshire and many other
parts of the country where you it's like
a day camp for therapy and you spend a
substantial amount of time Monday
through Friday in um in a therapeutic
environment going to uh meetings I think
it takes about a month and it's covered
by Insurance typically um so there's a
lot of different ways to address um
exacerbated and untreated mental health
issues um aside from incarceration in a
way that really takes you out of your
element and helps you
focus represent
new thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question um the way I read it
I mean it says the court may may impose
individually assess uh an individually
assess sentence so what we're what we're
saying here I think that or I just want
you to clarify if I have this correct
um so what we're saying here is you know
I'm sure that this is something that the
court may already take into
consideration just as part of you know
the way they're doing what you're trying
to say here is you're trying to um put
into law um uh the requirement
essentially for this to be considered
but it doesn't actually mean they have
to impose this kind of sentence over
another it's an option is what I'm
saying right and I think sometimes as
lawmakers we
sometimes I'm I'm frustrated when like
an attorney is a lawmaker because
they're always throwing a wrench in the
gears because they're on the other side
and they know how our attempts at
lawmaking end up playing out in real
lives um and I think that's the
importance of of communicating to the
court our wishes as a
legislature but then also giving the
court that
discretion because we can't legislate to
every every individual type of situation
we can't begin to imagine the variety of
predicaments that the court has to
address um and I'd like to think that a
judge in working with the prosecution in
working with the defense can determine
on a case-by casee basis this person
would really benefit from and would be
able to grow from going into therapy as
their sentence
instead of
incarceration or something along those
lines wonderful thank
you no um representative BRS thank you
Mr
chairman um on line I'm just looking at
line 13 on the second page can you just
clarify where it says affordable and
safe housing assistance is is that meant
to be public housing or it actually let
me not tell you what I think what what
does that mean um we have programs in
the state that help people
um go through the they assist them in
going through the process of obtaining
housing um when it comes to I mean I
don't know if you've really interacted
much with someone who's homeless um or
someone who's been applying for benefits
but for folks in that situation the
stress is so high
their emotions are running so High um
they feel so much shame that I mean I've
personally witness people trying to
apply for something helpful and it's
feels so invasive they feel so
scrutinized and it's really difficult to
move through the process and so we have
entities in this state that can help you
respect like respectfully help you and
encourage you to move through the
process of for example um you know
applying for a mortgage things like that
things that can be very daunting
especially if you have some mental
health
issues thank you and for the record I
was the welfare director in my town and
I've helped many people it's obvious
that you didn't I've helped many people
that were homeless I've helped many
people with their rent assistance I've
helped many people that had no places to
go I'm so my understanding is that if
the the reason I'm asking this specific
question is if an individual has a
felony on their record they weren't
allowed to apply for the public housing
and that's why I'm questioning
this uh okay I don't think you could be
sentenced to live in public housing that
would be weird um I think it's more
about um having assistance in obtaining
housing of any type but also I didn't
know about your work history and I just
generally think that very few people you
know so many people are just paying
their bills picking their kids up from
school focused on their lives and and
not a lot of people in my perspective
have the opportunity to watch someone
really crumble when they're faced with
paperwork and it sounds like you you
know firsthand what that's like and it's
rough
um as a parent of a teenager I've
certainly spent a lot of time trying to
manage just one human's emotions and the
work that social workers do I think is
beyond my
capacity represent
Newman thank you um in section three on
the the last page it it gives a um the
processes that the court can use then to
determine whether the person has been um
sentenced in accordance with this law to
be able to to follow up and determine if
the if the person is complying with with
what's necessary to be eligible um is
that does that appear anywhere else in
law or is is this a new thing that would
might be more helpful for for um a judge
to understand that there is certain
things that there's a process that they
can go through to make sure that it's
complied with I couldn't tell you if
there's anything like that anywhere else
in law but um this section is is worded
in this way to it's reflective of the
Tennessee law but um the Tennessee law
digs in deep and gives Specific
Instructions to the court and the in our
work crafting the language of this bill
talking to different stakeholders um it
was clear
that we would be creating more problems
than we'd be solving by giving specific
dictates to the court about how to go
about establishing whether someone has
met the requirements because they have
their own systems and procedures in
place already and so essentially the
idea is just to say whatever your
procedures are check in on
folks see no further questions oh oh oh
I'm sorry go
ahead I guess you go can I
go thank you Mr chair um thank you
representative balen for taking my
question I just have a question back to
the affordable and safe housing
assistance um that line 13 on page
two the the sentence prior uh says that
the the court may require the person to
meet certain conditions and then it said
affordable and safe housing assistance
is the requirement that they obtain
Assistance or is it the requirement that
they obtain affordable and safe
housing
did she um my read is assistance pardon
me
assistance um but it would be
appropriate to I mean honestly in this
housing market asking someone to obtain
housing as a condition of not being
incarcerated me is probably way too much
to ask um especially when you know you
have to take into consideration their
credit um their financial status it's I
think it's more about assist
and so for example if someone is
unhoused and they're being unhoused is
contributing in some way to whatever
bringing them back into the court system
um
then requiring them to do the work to
obtain housing um if the judge believes
that obtaining housing could have an
impact on their likelihood of uh ending
up in front of a judge again um then
that seems appropriate thank you can it
follow up thank you on on that same page
on page uh let's see line
25 is this um meant to if it talks about
the the person uh non-compliant person
having to reappear so they according to
line D in order for the the judge to um
impose the initial sentence of
confinement the person would have to be
non-compliant a couple of times
at least twice right because it says
it's of continued non-compliance because
initially they could just add sanctions
or something but okay thank
you no F the questions did represent fre
to have a question um yeah do you what
is it um do you know how successful the
the program is in the Tennessee how long
it's um I just know that it's Tennessee
and they passed this la and that blew my
mind because it is Tennessee I have a
cousin who lives there and um you know
the culture is
different thank you no further
questions Paul
introo indasa you get to pronounce these
first so I how about write them out for
then
CL
push the
button okay we're on yes uh thanks for
hearing me uh this morning for a couple
minutes I'm with the New Hampshire
Community bail fund and we're a
nonprofit that bails out folks who uh
are stuck in jail simply because they
they don't have the money to pay and one
of the things of course my phone's
ringing
sorry uh yeah I think I
think we've been busy believe me H any
case yeah they don't have uh the
resources to pay so and it's typically
Low Cash bail non-violent types of
situations uh We've in the last we've
bailed over 540 people throughout New
Hampshire and
275 just last year um and some one of
the things we do is we do give Brides to
people so we get to know some of these
folks uh uh when we can give a ride and
uh to give some color to some of the
people who are primary caregivers uh we
had one gentleman Dylan he called us in
a panic because he's legally blind and
he's uh he
can't uh keep track of his meds because
his caregiver isn't was in Valley Street
jail so that just kind of gives you an
idea of what that impact of just being
separated from your primary caregiver
giv
does we had another person uh Sarah who
uh we had a panic call from the attorney
so you got to get her out because if
she's not out by today she's going to
lose her job and she's going to lose her
kids so uh thankfully we had people
available to do that but again this
again this could this is just these are
minor crimes uh minor situations that
are impacting people people's lives uh
the other one um Debbie who was uh she
was in a her her apartment building uh
burned down and uh the next week she was
picked up on an old warrant for $100 of
a driving thing that happened like three
years prior uh she's got a
four-year-old and the four-year-old was
with her grandmother who's kind of
infirm so she was really worried about
the whole risk of that and she had spent
four four days in jail at Valley Street
just for
$100 so I I just wanted to give some
color on what the impact of just being
separated at when you're a primary
caregiver I know there's a lot of
details to sort through if we we could
move forward with this but I think this
is something that's something we really
got to consider and it definitely would
be a good step forward for the community
so thank you thank you any questions um
representative new thank you Mr chair
thank you for being here um my question
is you know what your I just said when I
was um speaking with um representative
balen um that you know this would be
something that would be taken into
consideration now and the way what
you're describing is it not being really
um it doesn't sound like it's being
taken into consideration can you speak
to kind of how often you see primary
caregivers um in in that type of
situation you know I don't have all the
um I I should go backtrack with our
folks but I'd say it's maybe about 10%
of the time we we we uh there is a
primary primary caregiver
involves um do you think that this would
be impactful and and help people who are
in that situation oh absolutely you know
and I just and the other thing I'm
worried about is what about the people
we can't get out you know the people
that can't get bail that that are
primary
caregivers thank
you represent Stone thank you for taking
my question my question is are these
individuals that you post bail for are
these individuals that have been seen
before the court or they prior to their
court appearance after being arrested
this is the people that we see are all
pre-trial thank you
yeah see no further questions thank you
for Testimony thanks um the chair
recognizes Pamela
Kylie
uh good morning Mr chair and members of
the committee my name is Pamela kyg and
I'm the public policy specialist at the
New Hampshire Coalition against Domestic
and Sexual Violence uh the Coalition is
the umbrella Organization for our 12
community- based crisis centers that
each year serve uh around
14,000 victims of Domestic and Sexual
Violence each year and that includes uh
children um I here in opposition to HB
1039 uh legislation that could
inadvertently Place domestic violence
victims and Children at Risk um we truly
appreciate the sponsor's commitment to
ensuring that children grow up in safe
and supportive homes in New Hampshire
especially when it comes to trying to
find solutions for children of
incarcerated parents and caregivers
unfortunately this proposal is in direct
conflict with the goals of Public Safety
normally we try to come to the table um
and I just want to say we oppose similar
legislation that was brought forward
last session um and raised very similar
concerns to what I'm going to address
here today um and so I think um better
Faith efforts could have been made to BR
bring broader stakeholders to the table
to really work through um some of the
pieces in here to see if we could bring
forward a better solution um I think the
underlying goal of this legislation has
Merit the implementation of such a
proposal really needs to be carefully
done even with substantial amendments to
today uh this proposal just isn't going
to satisfy our concerns um an integral
part of the coalition's mission is to
raise awareness and build Statewide and
local capacity to address the impact
that trauma can have on both victims and
their families it is especially
important that children who have been
exposed to abuse and violence in their
homes receive support and learning how
to cope um after these situations have
occurred exposure to domestic violence
is an adverse child experience and this
bill as written doesn't address uh the
impact that domestic violence could have
in a home we agree that children do well
in a stable environment have been
longtime supporters of Early Childhood
interventions that seek to increase
resiliency in children who have
experienced adversity however when
someone needs a caregiver whether it's
because of age disability or other
circumstances they're considered
especially vulnerable and sadly more
likely to be victimized we have an
obligation as members of a community to
protect our most vulnerable citizens
against harmful conduct by the people
responsible for their care in New
Hampshire we often hold caregivers to
higher standards and this bill as
written does the opposite in reviewing
the bill language we are concerned about
situations where the underlying member
who they're attempting to maintain care
over um could be actually charged or
could um be returned back to their
family even if they've abused their
dependent or child there's no car out in
here that addresses a situation like
that and I know that um the office of
child advocate has raised similar
concerns the bill ignores um the needs
of the child or the dependent in uh
these situations and doesn't guide the
court to consider the possibility of
whether the vulnerable person was the
victim um additionally many offenders in
New Hampshire plead to much less serious
crimes than they are originally charged
with and we see this often in cases of
sexual and domestic violence and child
abuse use consequently creating a
laundry list of perceived violent
offenses did not address the reality of
how these crimes are resolved in our
state I've attached a handout to the
testimony which I'll um uh which is a
chart of violent offenses like our
definitions of violent crimes in the
state and the laundry list of crimes
that could are harmful or dangerous that
aren't encompassed in that this bill
would then create another list of non or
violent crimes that again will create
further complications and um more
complexities in our statute um and it's
just creating a list of violent or
non-violent of crimes is the wrong
approach to this type of policy when the
goal is to both balance Public Safety
and ensuring that caregivers are able to
adequately care for their children um
just to want to just share a couple of
scenarios to kind of illustrate this so
in this bill RSA 169c which is the abuse
and neglect statute is not included in
this list
um that means that a caregiver could be
considered who maybe is on the central
registry for abusing their child but
maybe committed a crime that isn't on
this list of uh exemptions could then be
returned home we need to be looking at
all of the factors at the table and
understand how everything comes together
there needs to be a comprehensive
consideration of the whole situation not
peac meal or Patchwork approach to this
and another example this bill could also
create a situation where the caregiver
may have a protective order against them
under RSA 17 73b the domestic violence
statute also not listed in this um and
then they could then that abusive parent
could be returned home even if they
committed another crime not included on
this list additionally vulnerable adults
could also still be victims of financial
exploitation or criminal neglect as
relevant statutes are not addressed rest
here so we just I just we implore you to
consider sort of the broader
implications of this and make sure that
we're looking really holistically at
this so that we can really come to an
agreeable solution um we hope that you
will consider the best interest of the
child and domestic violence victims and
vulnerable adults when you're um making
your decision on this bill and we ask
you to itl thank
you representative
sake thank you and thank you for taking
my question um I'm a little confused
about some of your testimony because the
bill does specifically say people who
have committed domestic violence second
degree assault it also doesn't say that
it that these people have to be released
it's giving a judge discretion in the
cases where there's not been violence
committed um or assault committed and my
understanding is if you assaulted a
child or abused a child that you know
the judge would certainly take that into
consideration as a a reason not to take
this as an option that this isn't saying
the judge must but the judge May and and
so I just I don't understand where it
specifically addresses um certain things
that you're saying it doesn't seem to
address it it seems to be within here um
and that a person who in the best
interest of a child has arranged the the
temporary care care of a child it mean
it just focuses a lot on making sure
children are protected as well as elders
and so I I'm I'm just confused because
it doesn't seem to match at all with
what you're saying yeah no thank you so
much for that question and for the
opportunity to clarify so um I think to
point out um so this uh this bill
includes the definitions of violent
crime under RSA
6515 uh section 10 uh I can do this 13
um Roman numerals so I under that is a
is a list um and I'll show uh when I
send out the chart you'll see this a bit
more clearly on that list the only crime
under RSA 173b or sorry but there's this
list doesn't include any of the issues
under 173b this only includes the uh
actual crime of domestic violence under
RSA
631 um so what what I'm trying to say
here is that someone could violate a
protective order they could have these
other crimes of abuse against them like
animal cruelty and all of these other
things that show a pattern of domestic
violence and not be considered violent
in this case under this bill so there's
gaps in this that don't look at the
whole situation because domestic
violence under
173b is not a crime you have to have
certain um so it's it's a it's a gap in
the legislation to make sure it's
holistic what about her question
regarding the fact that it's only an
option for the judge versus mandatory
yeah um there's I know there's some
folks in the room that might be able to
better answer the legal process around
this but it's my understanding that
judges already have the discretion to um
make sentences tailored to the
individual so I also just don't know why
this is necessary to begin with and I
think if the goal is to bring children
and caregivers together then we need to
be looking at funding more programming
um to ensure sure that there's more
options to expand what we already have
in the state um and to make sure that it
can be very safely
designed one followup thank you if this
legislation had the list of offenses you
included as an amendment would you then
support it
we that thank you so much for asking
that question that is something we've
mold over um for a really long time I
just don't think the approach of
creating carve outs is going to
adequately address our concerns because
there's a plethora of scenarios that
we're not going to be able to
contemplate here and if we're especially
going to be saying that folks need to
them be matched to specific resources in
programming then I think we have need to
have a better idea of what those
resources in programming are and so I
think this just is going to need a lot
more work and discussion to better
understand who who is going to fall
under this umbrella and how we can
adequately support them to make sure
that this would be a successful
successful
proposal and just to be clear for the
members and anyone else um there will be
an opportunity to do that because I'm
going to put this on a subcommittee uh
representative
Newman thank you Mr chairman thank you
for taking my
question so it seems like the situation
that you've
described um the judge H has the ability
right now with any sentence without a
list to assign these particular
Solutions and now with this
legislation it has a list but he could
still is is that not correct or am I am
I not understanding the the discretion
that the judge has now yeah no um and I
again would love to defer that to
someone with a little bit more practice
in court than I do um have but I do
think like what I was trying to say is
currently judges do have discretion but
it doesn't it doesn't necessarily relate
directly to this bill but I think the
the biggest thing thing is just like I
don't think this solution fits within
the current framework that we have in
our state and so we're going to need to
do a lot more work to look at the whole
infrastructure um within this to make
sure that the judges have adequate
distraction and that the right pieces
then can fall into place but I defer to
Legal
experts see enough for the question oh
I'm sorry Mr Wheeler represent wheeler
thank you Mr chairman um I know a lot of
work went into this bill here uh and
they reached out to a lot of different
stakeholders um and I'm wondering did
the sponsor Prime sponsor reach out to
the domestic violence coalition to try
and alleviate some of those concerns and
have you uh work and find some way of
mulling it over together to find a
comprehensive solution yeah I think we
did um get there were a few efforts to
reach out and unfortunately we were not
able to connect on multiple occasions
and I really don't think there was a
good good faith effort there because it
was kind of in the 11th hour before the
filing period um I I think again we had
a a really strong list of concerns that
were presented when this bill was first
filed and so a lot of those concerns
continue to today and we've expressed
them over and over again and implored
them to speak to other stakeholders that
we knew had similar concerns I don't
know if those efforts were followed
through quick followup Mr chairman
followup and then I assume the domestic
violence Coalition will participate in
the subcommittee that the chairman has
said that he'll propose on this bill we
are more than happy to serve as a
resource we just want to be at the table
thank you and so you shall be um see you
no further questions thank you for your
testimony and the
chair calls ailia
brunette thank
you
thank
you so I just passed out um a fact sheet
that we all came together collectively
that worked on this bill and my
testimony good morning Mr chairman and
members of the committee my name is
ailia Brett and I am the healing Justice
pro program associate with the American
friends service committee I am here
today not only as I as a directly
impacted individual myself but I am also
here to advocate for those who are
currently informally incarcerated as
well I am here to testify in support of
HB 1039 and urge you to vote ought to
pass on this important
bill as one of the organizers who worked
closely on this bill the primary
caregiver bill is not a get had a jail
free card this legislation provides
communitybased alternatives to prison
for parents and primary caregivers with
nonviolent crimes and if the court
determines they are not a threat or a
danger to the community with bills like
PE like with bills like the primary
caregiver Bill the primary caregivers
can stay with their children and
families isn't that what we all want is
to try to keep families together instead
of tearing them apart we see so often
that what that looks like and the
long-term harm that it causes to
families there's
2,442 people currently incarcerated in
the state of New Hampshire many of them
are parents to young children having a
child separated from their parent at an
early age can negatively impact children
well into adulthood according to
American Health ranking when a parent is
in prison children suffer parent incar
parental incarceration is considered an
adverse childhood experience AC which is
correlated with the poor health and
education educational outcomes
behavioral issues and other Social
Challenges into adulthood nearly 16% of
children in New Hampshire have
experienced two or more
Aces I'd now like to take this moment to
read a letter from a woman who had to
leave her newborn baby behind to face
her jail sentence hello my name is Emy
Landry and I am from lonia New Hampshire
I have I have a daughter who will be
turning six in July of this year when I
was first incarcerated she was only a
month old the charges I received have
received had stemmed from before she was
conceived and although I found out after
my arrest that I was pregnant it did not
change the outcome at all I was
sentenced to County year and served 9
months out of the 12 that was my first
incarceration and there were no
Alternatives offered despite my efforts
there was very it was very difficult to
accept especially going through
postpartum depression behind walls due
to these circumstances I was lucky to
have a mother willing to step in to take
over temporary guardianship when I
couldn't be there I took a drug class in
County but the resources were lacking
upon release I had been struggling with
addiction since I was a teenager and
when I got out I still felt lost it was
difficult transitioning into being a
mother of a 10-month-old infant of whom
I was never there for the first year of
a child's life is crucial for bonding
and I wasn't even given that option I
was released out on probation where I
was violated multiple times for
continued drug use those violations
along with other charges led to a prison
sentence in which my daughter was almost
3 years old thankfully she was still
very young so she didn't grasp the
concept of exactly where I was she just
knew that her mother wasn't there during
my time in prison she was able to come
visit me which helped me build a better
relationship between the two of us the
transition back home was still difficult
because of the time I was coming home to
a toddler not the one-month-old baby I
left years ago during my incarcerations
my daughter started having medical
problems she she was getting sick often
and started showing signs of anger and
physical aggression she was kicked out
of multiple daycares due to concerns of
other children Her speech was delayed so
she was unable to communicate with her
wants and needs properly she has since
been diagnosed with ADHD as well as
being on excuse me she has since been
diagnosed with ADHD as well as being on
autism spectrum she has an is she has an
individual learning program at school
and does speech therapy three times a
week if we were to rewind back a few
years to the charges that started this
all I personally believe there could
have been a better solution I was in the
full swing of my long addiction when I
was arrested for sales and conspiracy to
sell drugs I found out almost a year
later after my arrest I was pregnant
with my daughter and pleaded with my
lawyer to try to find an alternative to
being locked up whether it was house
arrest on a bracelet counseling
community service a long-term treatment
facility or all the above they said
there wasn't on the that it wasn't on
the table and I would have to serve time
or in county jail or in the state prison
there was no middle ground I truly
believe if this had been an option that
my path as well as my daughters could
have been drastically different
different it's almost 6 years since my
first incarceration and I'm thankful to
say that I have been sober now four of
those years and out of prison for almost
three to enjoy time with my daughter and
build a relationship I was denied in the
beginning it hasn't been the easiest and
I'm still going to court to get back fil
custody and dissolve the guardianship
had leg has had we had legislation back
then like HB 1039 Emmy would have been
received the proper care she needed
which was going to be substance care
counselor
because as you see incarceration did not
help emy's case she kept violating
because of the drug misuse incarceration
did not fix that honestly statistic has
shown that incarceration only causes
more harm but that's a conversation and
topic for another day but had she had
the alternative to incarceration and got
the counsel counseling she needed she
would not have kept violating and
missing those most important and
Precious Years of her daughter's life
and would have been there for her
daughter because as you see her daughter
was experiencing a few Aces that I had
mentioned before due to parental
incarceration so please chairman and
members of the committee the time is now
support HB 1039 let's invest in
treatment job training and affordable
housing so we can help provide families
like Emmy with the resources and the
support they need to thrive with
community- based alternatives to prison
that allow caregivers of all types of
with all types to remain in their
families and their communities thank
you and I will take any questions if
anyone has
one see no questions thank you for your
testimony today thank
you the chair calls Richard
balinsky did I put
you all right uh attorney Steven
Enders
good morning chair members of the
committee my name is Stephen endis I'm a
prosecutor in the uh marac County
Attorney's Office I've been a prosecutor
for over 20 years I I do oppose this
legislation simply because I believe
it's
unnecessary um let me start out by by
reading you a quote from the New
Hampshire Supreme Court
Court in 1978 the New Hampshire Supreme
Court wrote the real purpose of all
sentencing is to reduce crime this
theoretically can be done by
rehabilitating the individual defendant
so he will not offend again another way
is to punish the individual defendant in
the hope that he'll be deterred from
repeating his crime moreover by
punishing the individual defendant
others may be deterred from committing
crimes whichever sentence is thought to
be likely to reduce the most crime is
the proper sent sentence to
impose and that's something that I think
judges live by and understand in the
state of New Hampshire and in New
Hampshire everybody gets an individually
assessed sentence there are very very
few crimes that have minimum mandatory
penalties and when I say very very few I
haven't gone through and looked to try
and count them up but my guess would be
there's under 10 of them throughout the
entire criminal code in fact I know in
2016 the legislature formed a
subcommittee to look at all of the
crimes that did have minimum mandatory
sentences and look at whether or not
those minimum mandatory sentences were
appropriate I know as a result of that
2016 subcommittee they changed one
statute most of the crimes in the state
of New Hampshire that have minimum
mandatory sentences have prerequisite
crimes meaning for example armed career
criminal has a minimum mandatory
sentence but in order in order to be an
armed career criminal you need to have a
certain number of prerequisite violent
felonies on your
record the list of options in this bill
the a through I list are available in
all cases to all
defendants so I don't believe that it's
necessary to carve out an exception
saying for caregivers only for
non-violent offenses only because judges
in this state have discretion to impose
this
inappropriate
cases I'm also concerned with paragraph
three which requires a person to
potentially reappear in court after
sentencing I think there would be um
constitutional challenges to that
because it theoretically allows the
court to change the sentence after it's
imposed one of the tenants in New
Hampshire is that once a sentence is
imposed everyone leaving the courtroom
at the end of sentencing needs needs to
know exactly what that sentence is and
exactly what the parameters of that
sentence
are in terms of communicating to the
court
system um that the
legislature is is hoping the court will
will impose these options a through I as
Miss keig said I think the appropriate
way to communicate that is to fund these
programs because I think there's a real
concern now we we love programming I can
tell you as a prosecutor I love programs
because if a program is going to stop
crime that's
fantastic defense attorneys love
programs too because if it keeps their
client out of jail and keeps their
client out of jail for the rest of their
client's life they love
programs the problem is finding these
programs that don't always necessarily
exist and as usual I'm happy to answer
any
questions thank you um
with regard to
the I I understood that the court
already had the opportunity or the
availability to use all these in the
list but what about the message of
legislative preference I know that for
example um it used to be in
Massachusetts um when it came to
domestic violence arrest it used to say
the preferred shall be
arrest can the legislature not send its
its intent that our preference would be
that they take take into account in the
cases of uh
caregivers I assume the legislature's
preference is to stop
crime in terms of stopping people from
committing
crimes I think that's the Court's
preference as well I think we're all on
the same page in terms of our goal as
the government all three branches is to
stop crime the question is how does that
occur her um and if the legislature has
a preference for
programming that that's fine you can I
think say the legislature prefers that
the court impose programming other over
incarceration but I think that with that
goes providing that programming to the
court so that they can actually go with
that uh with regard to your
constitutional concern about the um
changing of the sentence is it not not
similar to a suspended sentence if they
were to if if they impose a
incarceration and then say okay we're
going to enact the car I mean it looks
like they would be imposing a whole new
sentence but if it were written as a
suspended sentence would that be
absolutely if it were written as a
suspended sentence where when the person
is sentenced they know I
have you know two to five in the state
prison that's suspended for a period of
time conditioned on me doing these
things that's certainly legal if the
person doesn't do those things we could
file a motion to impose that sentence
they'd be entitled to an attorney they'd
be entitled to a due process hearing and
then the court could impose the portion
of of the suspended sense they felt
appropriate um
this leaves it much
more Squishy in terms of not having a
suspended sentence in the court saying
that in the event of non-compliance
impose sanctions those sanctions need to
be told to the defendant at the time of
sentencing in terms of this is what we
will do if you don't do
this thank you representative wheeler
thank you Mr chairman so you said the
caregiver exception is not needed
because judges have the discretion to
make that exception themselves so I'm
wondering what should the committee do
and I assume there might be a sub
commmittee what should the committee do
about the situation that uh Paul
testified to when it when it comes to
someone like like Dylan the legally
blind person who uh can't keep their is
going to because their caregiv was going
to jail they can't keep their medicine
and so we're hearing that this is
happening I guess the question is how
would your office see as best to address
the fact that some of these care givers
are going to prison and and people are
being left by the
wayside there's number of ways sentences
get imposed the the first and I think by
far the most common way in New Hampshire
is people come to an agreement on what
the sentence is going to
be um in those cases where people come
to an agreement over what the sentence
is going to be which again is the vast
majority of cases I I don't know there's
anything we can do to say um you know
these are some of the the the thoughts
about the the the dependent um certainly
that should be factored in in those
conversations between the defense and
the prosecution in coming up with an
agreement other ways sentences get
imposed is it it's left up to the court
it can be left up to the court after a
plea it can be left up to the court
after a contested hearing but when it's
left up to the court people can provide
Witnesses evidence um people can come in
and testify write letters sentencing
there's very few parameters for
sentencing in New Hampshire in terms of
keeping information out or letting
information in and certainly at a
contested hearing that person would be
welcom to say I'm a caregiver and people
depend on me and if I go to jail it's
going to not just impact me but it's
going to impact the community it's going
to you know present difficulties for a
variety of people um and then the judge
would make a determination based on all
of that
information I don't I hope that answers
your question
I think it does so you're saying that um
if and I'm just going to use the example
that was given again if there was a
legally blind person who wasn't getting
their medicine because their caregiver
was going to prison you're saying that
that person would the way that at least
the attorney's office thinks that that
person should go about this is petition
the court send letters get the person
who's getting care and other people who
might be affiliated with that to go to
the court sentencing hearing and
participate in that to make it clear
that there might be some
reason why absolutely and and I think it
depends too what the caregiver is going
to prison for or going to jail for I
think right well yes you and then obious
really quickly Mr chairman I just want
to make sure your name is spelled
correctly on my notes here because I
feel like I've been spelling it wrong
the last few days that you've been here
it's Steven with a V and it's endress e
n d r s e n d okay thank you thank you
just a a question for me um is it not
common do you not regularly hear defense
attorneys when it comes to sentencing
say my client is responsible for ab andc
and he has you know these conditions and
is that not AB absolutely I mean we hear
that all the time from from defense
attorneys
that and those are things that are taken
into consideration and nothing prohibits
the judge from considering those when
weighing a sense absolutely and again a
lot of this is negotiation between the
defense and the prosecution and
the vast majority of times we're able to
come up with an agreement that sort of
everyone can live with including the
defendant the victims the prosecutor
defense counsel um and then we would
present that agreement to the court and
the court would have to approve it if we
can't come to an
agreement we end up having contested
sentencing hearings and even in those
contested sentencing hearings there are
often parameters there's a sort of a
naked sentencing hearing where it's
anybody can ask for whatever they want
we also do cap sentencing hearings where
essentially the state is going to ask
for a certain sentence and the defense
is going to argue for anything below
that and there's also the possibility to
do capped floor sentencing arguments
where the state's going to ask for one
thing the defendants going to ask for
something lower and the court can impose
anything within those two parameters
that cap floor so it's it's not always a
throw yourself on the mercy of the court
but certainly every defendant if they
want to have a an open sort of naked
sentencing that's their right to do
so representative Harry
Katherine thank you Mr chair and thank
you for taking my question earlier you
stated that um in section three it said
that it requires the person to appear in
court um um I'm going to say the line 18
and line 20 says may correct and there
is a difference so I just want to make
sure that we're on the same absolutely
it doesn't require them to appear but it
may require them to appear so again
that's sorry finish a statement my
concern is that that would violate the
current um principles of due process in
terms of finality of
sentencing okay follow up follow so um
again for me who's not a lawyer we look
at that as being a discretion uh the
judge is that not correct if it says
may it's my concern with that paragraph
is that at the moment you're sentenced
you need to know exactly what the
sentence is and what the parameters of
that sentence are so if at the moment of
sentencing the judge says I'm sentencing
you to drug and alcohol treatment and
then two months later the judge says I
would like to see you to see how you're
doing in that drug and alcohol treatment
I believe that runs a fowl of the
finality of sentencing I think the Judge
can say I'm sentencing you to drug and
alcohol treatment and we're going to
have review hearings every two months to
see how you're doing and if you're not
successful in drug and alcohol treatment
this is the sentence I'm going to impose
but has to be known to the defendant at
the time of initial
sentencing go ahead okay with that said
thank you for that information um would
you be willing to work with the group on
that issue as well absolutely all right
thank you thank you just so um if you
could help me so everyone understands at
sentencing you're
either sentenced to further further
um further
supervision by the court or not correct
you can't be the court can't just kind
of reach out and pull you back in if
you're not sentenced to it correct so
you could be sentenced to probation and
part of that could be going to this this
and this and if you don't you could be
violated and have a new hearing yes
which would impose a new sentence for
violation probation correct okay so you
can't just be the judge will call you
back and check on you and if you're not
doing well he's going to send you to
jail correct okay thank you um
representative new new
thank you Mr chair um I'm thinking about
drug and mental health courts and kind
of how this interacts with that and I
know that you know it's an evolution and
you know they're being um expanded over
time I think mental health courts is is
much more recent and I'm wondering how
this kind of interacts with this and how
you would think that um that these the
interplay between these things well
there is a drug court program and a
mental health court program in maram
County right now um the the drug court
program is a program for people who who
do have substance misuse issues they
apply to get in they have to be screened
accepted um and my understanding is that
that has a higher rate of success than
sort of the standard incarceration model
um mental health court at this point I
believe is only for misdemeanors in in
maram County but I know they've looked
at expanding that as well and I think
again as I said earlier everyone in New
Hampshire gets an individually assess
sentence and if drug court or mental
health court is
appropriate hopefully that's what the
judge imposes could I follow up really
quick okay um and so in the example that
ailia gave thank you for that um
speaking about I think it was Emma um
the situation that that she went through
um without um and repeatedly you know
but do you think that now um clearly
that was a few years ago do you think
that now a person in that same situation
may have been diverted to drug court
instead potentially um it's tough to say
without knowing that and again like
you're saying it's very difficult to
know without knowing all the
circumstances of that case but certainly
as I said earlier our goal is to to stop
crime and our goal is to stop people
from getting arrested and if someone
says to me look sending this person to
jail isn't going to essentially cure the
problem but drug court will
I think 10 out of 10 judges are going to
send the person to drug court because
that's our
goal thank
you representative
Jamber thank you Mr chairman thank you
for taking my question it's been a while
since I was in college for my degree in
criminal justice so I I'm I'm hoping
that you could give me some information
that I'm I hope I'm correct yes um prior
to sentencing for a felony the New
Hampshire parole department probation
parole department does a pre-sentence
investigations is that still correct not
as much anymore okay that that used to
be a standard practice I think that's
not as um I think it's a potential but I
think it's less common than it was in
the past okay followup follow um if that
were the practice today do you believe
that the assessment uh that is required
in section two of the bill
uh to determine because it says the the
sentence in court will determine would
that investigation be helpful to the
court if this was to
happen I I think more information is
always helpful to the court in making a
decision so I think if um what you're
referring to is used to be a called a
PSI a PR sentence investigation those
PSIs I think were helpful to the court
in the sense that probation or parole
would talk to um the state they would
talk to the defendant they would talk to
defense counsel they' talk to any of the
victims and would make a recommendation
to the court saying this is what we
believe in appropriate sentences um so I
think all certainly if I was a judge
sentencing people I would want more
information rather than
less representative
Newman I have a question about the uh
current law yes and the current law in
sentencing and it's 6
6512 subparagraph 4 d and I'll just read
it it's very short upon recommendation
by the Department of Corrections are by
the county department of corrections a
court May sentence an in an
incarceration bound offender to a
special alternative incarceration
program involving
short-term confinement followed by
intensive community so to me that sounds
a lot like this except for the
short-term confinement and I'm wondering
about when it says intensive Community
Supervision what does that realistically
mean in in the state now um are any of
these things that are on the list that
might be considered uh is that part of
Community Supervision do you have any
thoughts on that law and and what it
says yes and it's a relationship to what
we're talking about right now yes so
there there is a program and the name is
escaping me right now where a person
does a short period of incarceration
during that period of incarceration they
go through um a drug treatment program
and then they're released into the
community on uh probation supervision
but it's a more intensive probation
supervision than sort of standard
probation where maybe instead of being
checked in you know a couple times a
week by a phone you have a probation
officer visit your home more often uh
that type of thing and that program does
in fact exist in New Hampshire at this
time thank
you see no further questions thank you
for your testimony thank you the chair
calls Grace
kcki
hello good after oh still the morning it
feels like you've been here a little
while uh so thank you to the committee
for taking my testimony today my name is
Grace K I am the program coordinator for
the American friend service committee
New Hampshire program uh and we are here
to urge the committee to vote to pass HB
turn
1039 um because having incarcerated uh
parent is is and can be in and of itself
a childhood an adverse childhood
experience this is an opportunity for
New Hampshire to take the lead and to
join three other states in passing
legislation that would expand discretion
in the courts for non-violent offenders
who are the caregivers of children edly
or disabled loved ones who are not also
the victims of those perpetrators and so
our Coalition I just wanted to address a
couple of things as I've heard
throughout the meeting and to say that
our Coalition has worked very hard over
the last year in good faith to address
some of the weaknesses of the bill from
the last session we have reached out to
multiple stakeholders have had very
informative conversations in order to
ensure that our bill um addresses those
two key concerns about the impact that
it would have on uh victims as well as
the impact that it would have in the
courts to ensure that sentencing was
made clear to uh those who are you know
in front of the judge during their
sentencing and throughout their their
case cases and so we have reached out to
not only Representatives within the
parole and the probation system we have
reached out and talked with Office of
the child advocate New Hampshire Public
Defenders and of course directly
impacted community members I would like
to make note that we have also done
quite a bit of work to reach out and
have conversations with the Coalition
for domestic violence um we have this
these overtures began in the summer of
2023 via phone and email um and after
multiple weeks of of reaching we were
able to get about 10 minutes with Miss
uh Miss keig um myself and my associate
ofilia uh brunette who you just heard a
moment ago um this isn't something that
I often speak about it's deeply personal
um but I feel that it is important to
make note of today I myself am the
victim of a crime um I experience um
horrific events as a child here in the
state of New Hampshire where I grew up
um and I knew that I where I come from
even though I've never had an
incarcerated parent although I have
incarcerated loved ones that this bill
is still vital and important and will
have an A A positive and outward impact
on many people in this Comm in this
community and so despite these multiple
attempts um and being able to only have
about 10 minutes with the with the
coalition to hear their concerns and do
our best to incorporate them um our
efforts afterward to reach out and to
share what we have put together what we
were going to submit to the to the
legislature were rebuffed and we never
heard back from the Coalition so we
continue to want to work together with
stakeholders with the community to
ensure that this bill both is makes
sense is sensible as well as um truly um
something that can create positive
impact in the New Hampshire community
and so one of the things that I so with
all that being said and I apologize I'm
a little bit shaky cuz again it's not
information that I I feel most
comfortable speaking with in um a body
of my peers but um I think what's also
important is that at afsc we have the
immense privilege to be able to work
directly with impact directly impacted
people who have either themselves
experienced incarceration or have loved
ones who have experienced incarceration
and we know that incarceration is not
always the solution especially for
low-level offenses for non-violent
offenses often which are sometimes even
often drug related and these things
require treatment they require support
um and that incarceration is not always
the answer and so what I would like to
do is to read a brief testimony from a
woman who was incarcerated a Community
member in New Hampshire who was
incarcerated who was not able to be with
us today because she does have her own
caregiving responsibilities um but would
wanted to make sure that the committee
heard her word
today and so this is from Susie I
support the primary caregiver bill
because it makes sense for our community
I have lived experience as a formerly
incarcerated woman who was separated
from her children for quite a few years
beyond the financial impact which
directly influenced my children there
were they were othered by the stigma of
having an incarcerated parent
incidentally now my son is being treated
for anxiety as well as other
psychological concerns due to this
separation
upon my return home I noticed my I had
my my own inability to manage activities
of daily living to needed to support
three small children I imagined that my
brain atrophied from years of sitting
idle with limited decision-making and
responsibilities in prison it also added
to my own complex um PTSD this is
important because my children have lived
the reifications of my lack of mother
and skills since I returned home from
prison if we rewind some decades I had a
high ad adverse childhood experience
score making me more susceptible to
incarceration while this is not an
excuse at all for my behavior it is not
worthy to look at the roots of these
problems I believe that New Hampshire
can break the cycle of recidivism and
think big picture to see that this bill
will have Ripple effects that will
benefit many in our communities perhaps
you thinking that this bill would allow
people to forego accountability my
personal experience and those that I
have witnessed did not allow for True
accountability inside the walls of
prison where our nervous systems were
continually activated due to the shaming
and punitive environment as well as a
separation from our loved ones perhaps
you're thinking that prison is the only
way to keep our community safe but
prisons have been around for hundreds of
years and yet we continue to face safety
threats from individuals who are
traumatized abused and suffering from
mental health issues as well as
substance abuse the recidivism rate is
high because we are failing to address
the root causes of the problem and to
remember that hurt people also hurt
people we can do better and we can do
better by passing HB
1039 and so I would like to close my
testimony by making note that overall
the incarceration rates in New Hampshire
are far below the national average and
the prison population has been declining
and this is positive news because it
shows that the E our efforts the efforts
of this committee as well as the efforts
within our judicial system are doing
exactly what um Mr Enders was speaking
of is ensuring that crimes are not being
committed right and so this is an
opportunity this bill is a way another
way an additional way that we can add to
continue to safely reduce the prison
population further leading to prison
closures saving taxpayer dollars and all
the while keeping families together and
so I urge you to um I'm no legal expert
but I also wanted to just quickly
address the well as well that in
speaking with um law experts in crafting
this bill as a coalition we were very
very thoughtful about thinking about
would this go adverse to the um the due
process that the importance of making
sure that everyone who comes in front of
a judge knows exactly what the terms of
their sentence is and so this bill would
be an additional tool in the toolbox of
the courts to say these are options this
is an addition that we can add on to
your sentence and as long as you meet
those conditions you meet those
requirements then the terms of the terms
of your sentence will not end in
incarceration this is not a way to slip
through the cracks or to go underneath
the system but is an additional way for
our system to continue um bolstering the
trend that we are seeing of making sure
that people can be held accountable that
families can stay together that
communities can remain intact and we can
continue having a safer State and a
safer Community for all so I'm happy to
take any
questions
seeing no questions thank you thank
you
um
really the chair calls gelis glan Glenn
gelli good
morning thank you for having me um I'm
going to be speaking from a different
from uh a a few a few um different
points of
view um before I before I uh before I
give my testimony I just wanted to I
wanted to touch on a few of the things
that I heard from some from the other
from the people who are opposing the
bill and it's it's it's very it's pretty
easy when you are not the one that's
sitting on the defendant side of the
table and me going be I've been through
the system um more than i' like to admit
so I I know I know firsthand that the
courts and all of these all of these
legal systems have a bias so yes they
have discretion but their discretion is
always leaning towards whatever the
prosecutor is suggesting so we don't
really have a chance unless there's some
a bill like this that's that says you
know Al like a law that needs to be
followed along with the other ones as
far as the sentence being sentenced and
then returning back there are such
things as review hearings you can the
you can be sentenced to this and then be
sentenced later on date come back as for
a review hearing see if you completed
anything and then you sentence ends that
day and you're convicted that day I've
been through
that
um
also
uh from from from the criminals point of
view when when people are out there
committing crimes and doing things that
are against the law the last thing that
they're thinking about is how much time
they can get for doing it they're not
thinking about the punishment in the
moment and not that that's not that's
not something that's being evaluated as
they commit these crimes as these crimes
are committed so the the more the worse
the punishment or the higher the the the
longer the time is not going to make a
difference in preventing people from
committing
crimes um and as far as um I heard
someone say that it doesn't fit within
the
infrastructure no it they're right it
does not fit within the infrastructure
that's the whole point it doesn't fit
within the infrastructure we are we have
enough they have enough things under
their their in under their umbrella in
their infrastructure to impose sentences
and and sentence and convict people
where's the where is the help it's not
it's not a it's not a secret that
Rehabilitation is the key to to uh to
reform people who are who are coming out
of the prisons it's not it's not a
secret this is known for many years
through many
studies so they're right it does not fit
within the infrastructure
um so now I would like to read my
testimony um I'd like to briefly share a
part of my story the part the part that
left the deepest wound in my heart for a
sake of time I'm just going to summarize
um some of this some of my my upbringing
and things um I grew up with my mother
who's Dominican Republic and I and I can
count on one hand how many times I saw
my father before he died I'm the oldest
of three on my mom's side my mother
remarried when I was 8 years old this
would be this would become my brother's
my young my brother's father and also my
abuser I was sexually molested from the
time that I from from that time of 8
years old until my late teens I had been
sexually abused for the majority of my
life at that point and I had actually
believed that I was just fine yet the
following years would come to prove that
I was not fine that I was not that I was
not fine I was not mentally fine I was
not emotionally fine I was not fine in
any way I had my first child at 17 when
I started going to jail I had four kids
and one on the way looking for love in
all the wrong places I got I got
involved with I got involved with the
wrong people and wanted I wanted to feel
like I belong somewhere anywhere I it
didn't really much matter where I just
wanted to belong long story short I
ended up having to serve a two year two
to four year sentence I had DCF
involvement due to my drug use and I was
their Prime and I was their primary
caregiver I made sure they were fed
clothed and sheltered no matter what I
had to do to to make sure that that
happened my mother was babysitting one
day and I was extremely stressed out and
I uttered that I was going to jump off
of the bridge to my mother I wouldn't
never go I would never go through with
it like anything like that it's just how
I felt at that time my mother told DCF
that I had said that that I had said
that and they instructed her not to
allow me to not to allow me to see my
children my mother having a language
barrier didn't understand the ver the
veracity of the situation my children
wanted to come home with their mother
and she brought them to me DCF found out
and re remove them from her care the 12-
month clock to fix the life that I had
spent my entire life messing up started
ticking being in prison didn't make me
an exempt ultimately the time
termination of parental rights rolled
around I was able to prove my 5year
sobriety I was no longer the same person
I did I I did a complete sustainable
180 I had set out to proed that I
deserved my own children back I was
convinced that I had that I had that the
fact is I never had a chance my parental
rights were terminated because I did not
comply within 12 months I wasn't aable
to obtain suitable shelter I had one
last visit with them 14 years
ago when they were four five and six
years
old had this bill been in place during
that time I would have had a better
chances of regaining custody of my
children because I I want because at
that time I did um I had submitted to
the court to to uh me to amend my
sentence to be able to uh to Le to go
into a program instead of um committing
the rest of my the remainder of my time
and it was denied so the judge's
discretion didn't help me in that
case it's too um someone someone else uh
I had this bill been in place during
that time I would have I would have had
better chances of regaining custody of
my children it's too late for that for
me anyway but it doesn't have to be tooo
late for someone else someone else
experienced a Sim similar situation this
would help eliminate having to cause
more trauma than necessary to the
innocent parties involved I have lived
experience I've endured many things in
my life but none compared to the pain of
losing three of my children at one time
I think it's time we shift the direction
this year we claim to provide re
rehabilitation in these Correctional
Facilities when we know it's not true
when will when will we start to
listening to the ones who've been
through it the ones who know firsthand
who who knows better than than one who's
been through it someone up there knows
better than what knows better what I've
been through than me support this bill
show the people show the people what
Rehabilitation looks like the Resto the
restorative justice looks like what
alternative sentencing looks like what
Rehabilitation not incarceration looks
like thank
you representative
Muse just one quick question and I'm I'm
sorry if for for what you've been
through um you said something right at
the beginning of your testimony that was
really interesting um judges have
discretion but they also have
biases um to what extent do you think a
law like this would be helpful
in maybe sending a message to judges
that they need to consider things like a
defendant family situation um and not
just uh
um I guess not not simply other factors
associated with the crime so to what
extent do you think this bill would
actually be really useful in
helping maybe change what you went
through for somebody else I would think
it would help because if it's passed
then the judge would the judge would
have to he would have to abide by it
because it would be law just like all
the other laws so they would have to
abide by it wouldn't be a suggestion or
a recommendation it would be something
that's in black and white that has to be
followed just like all the other ones
that's how I think it would it would
help I mean we we we all know that there
are plenty of cases that you know go to
appeals because all all the things are
not followed within the courts and
that's just the little ones that we
that's just the small things that we
know of there's so many there there's so
many things that like hearing the
prosecutor up here talking they love
programs they love programs well then
how come there aren't any more people in
programs how come there's more people in
prison than anywhere else if they love
programs so much I mean that's just
that's all Bs to be honest with you
that's what that's what he was up here
sitting talking because nothing that he
really said was was actually anything
based on fact and that whatever that
quote was that he said the two choices
well we all know by by by the studies
and by the proof that we've been
incarcerating people for how long have
we been incarcerating people how long
has it made the problem better has the
punishments made people behave no
because that's not what they need we
need to get to the root of the problem
we need to find out what's making these
people do this why are they doing this
what caused them you know what caused
them being taken away from their mother
at the age of four and 5 years old and
never seeing their parents again
thinking that they were neglected and
Abandoned and left and weren't loved
that's what's causing that that's the
root of that problem I mean not the only
one but that's part of it so we need to
we we need to start want punish punish
everybody wants to punish until it's
until it's the other way around until
the table is turned then then people get
some sense of humanity and empathy and
compassion and sympathy for other people
because we're not all from the same
place we didn't all get the same things
growing up and we we didn't all don't
all handle the same things the same
way
followup
yeah I just uh could you repeat your
name again gelli thank you thank
you see no further questions thank you
for your
testimony
good morning uh my name is Brian Townsen
II I'm a senior Assistant Attorney
General at the New Hampshire Department
of Justice I'm the prosecutor for New
Hampshire's elder abuse and financial
exploitation unit um the unit is
responsible for uh Prosecuting crimes
committed against our elder population
that's individuals 60 years of age and
older uh I'm speaking today in
opposition of House Bill uh
1039 uh I won't rehash uh what others
have said in opposition although I agree
with much of
it um what I will say is my uh
perspective here um in terms of uh a
message that wants to be sent surely
this bill is not mandatory if it passes
the court is not mandated to uh provide
alternative sentencing um but as the
members of this committee have said and
as the sponsor said this sends a signal
to judges um asserting a preference a
preference for what um this legislature
wants to see
happen and so in that respect um I would
ask the committee to think long and hard
about that message because I think they
are glaring omissions from House Bill
1039 and that is consideration of uh
Financial crimes committed against um
elderly individuals older adults in this
state um representative uh uh uh Balden
provided that this focuses on and allows
for alternative sentencing of minor
crimes I would dispute that um just
because a crime is uh non-violent does
not mean it is a minor crime I prosecute
cases throughout this state and have
done so for the last six years involving
um the theft by caregivers by
fiduciaries from their own dependence um
of tens of thousands hundreds of
thousands of
dollars these have devastating impacts
on these individuals who would be
considered dependents under this bill um
and uh they are victims of these crimes
this bill does not contemplate when the
dependent is a victim of a financial
crime committed by the caregiver and I
think that is a a glaring Omission um
and so in terms of a message that uh
would be sent by um passing this law um
I I think that is one glaring Omission
the other thing I will say is that it is
in um direct contrast to other
sentencing requirements and financial
crimes so uh the legislature has passed
under
6516 uh 1l um an extended term of
imprisonment for uh individuals who
commit Financial crimes including theft
and fraud um against elderly and
disabled individuals and so uh this
would be in contrast to that uh you
would be suggesting that there should be
alternative sentencing uh or at least
allowing for alternative sentencing at
the same time that you were saying uh
that uh there should be an extended term
of imprisonment for these individuals so
that's really it I'm happy to uh take
questions um but again I'm not going to
sit here and repeat uh what the
Coalition said or what attorney Enders
said thank you um with regard to that we
heard it as well with um as far as
potentially returning victims to a home
where they were abuser and in this case
I'm assuming returning someone back to
where they financially abused an
elder if the bill
hypothetically had a a a trigger
mechanism where someone could be
stripped of the status or of caregiver
in the case if they
were if they were to be returned to a
victim in other words if if the crime
they're there for is victimizing someone
who would give them caregiver status
would it not possibly be then to say
okay you don't qualify for that status
um I I think that would be helpful I
think that would be a start would it fix
all the problems with the bill it would
not yeah um I think part of the bigger
concern is carving out um just
non-violent offenses um you know again U
representative Balden provided that this
would be a narrow subset of the law it's
really not um it's it's it's dealing
with a whole uh you know panoply of of
financial crimes out there of which
there are many identity fraud um U uh
Financial exploitation which includes
within it um although not violent um
undo influence coercion threats of of
violence uh and things of that nature
thank you other
questions representative
scitech how many such how many such
instances of financial crimes do you
think occur in the State per
year uh in the State per year um I can
just tell you that in terms of financial
exploitation referrals uh we get 35 a
week um so uh we get upwards of just shy
of 2,000 a year uh referrals are all of
them um valid uh the county the counties
handle um a lot of them but I can tell
you just from the referrals that we get
it's it's approximately 35 a
week representa s thank you and thank
you for taking my question um the bill
provides that the judge may do these
things but not shall do these things and
would you agree that a well-trained
well-educated judge which hopefully
would be all of our judges um would take
into consideration that putting the
perpetrator of a crime back into the
home of the person against whom they
committed the crime would not be
advisable and therefore would not use
this as the appropriate uh
followup thank you for your question I I
would hope so um absolutely but I think
making an Express uh makes a lot of
sense here and in addition um again if
you are providing a message or sending
an intention uh above and beyond what is
already authorized as discretionary by
the court um I would I would urge this
committee uh to have within it that
intent that specifically includes not
placing a caregiver back in the same
home where they have victimized a
dependent thank you thank you for your
testimony thank you very much
is is there anyone else wishing to
testify in this bill who has not yet
testified in this
bill seeing none I hereby close the
public hearing we will be taking a uh
15minute break and we'll return after
that
I'm opening the public hearing on House
Bill 1097 and invite the sponsor to
introduce their
bill
thank you Mr chair good morning Mr chair
committee members and guests today I'm
here sponsoring a bill that allow single
party recording of
conversations this issue is brought to
my attention by a constituent after
doing research and doing a deep dive
into this issue I see the importance of
being here today and presenting this to
the committee single party recording is
the practice of recording a conversation
or an interaction without the consent or
knowledge of the other
party this may sound unethical or
illegal but in fact it's perfectly legal
in 36
States why would anybody want to record
a conversation without another person's
consent well this may benefit reasons
for doing so and I will share them with
you today first of all single party
recording can provide personal safety
and protection against false accusations
imagine you're in a situation where you
are threatened harassed assaulted by
someone if you have a recording device
with you you can capture the evidence
with a crime use it to report to the
authorities and defend yourself in a
court of law this can also deter the
perpetrator from hiring you in the
future if they know they can be
recorded an example would be in 2019 a
woman in New York recorded her boss
sexually harassing her at work she used
this recording as proof to file a
lawsuit against him and the company the
recording was also exposed the toxic
work environment in the culture that was
involved in the company and the
organization
itself another benefit of single party
recording is that it can help
journalists activists expose corruption
Injustice abuse and power journalists
and activists often face dangers and
obstacles when they try to uncover the
truth and inform the
public they may be denied access
intimidated or attacked by those that
are trying to silence them by recording
these interviews meetings and encounters
with the sources and officials they can
protect themselves and other sources and
also document the facts of their stories
an example of this was in a case of Mike
Stanton a former investigative reporter
of Providence
Journal he did a hidden tape uh in an
interview that he was doing with the son
of a bob
Moss uh Stanton's recordings revealed
that the Bob the m boss was involved in
racketeering extortion murder and he had
connections to corrupt politicians and
law enforcement officials Stanton's
articles led to federal indictments and
several of his associates helped to
influence this and the state of Rhode
Island
another benefit of single partnering
coord is this can enhance the technology
landscape and enable Innovation and
creativity with the advancement of
Technology of recording devices have
become more affordable and versatile for
people to use you can record on your
smartphone your Smartwatch your laptop
Etc you can also use various apps to
record conversations this opens up new
possibilities for personal and
professional protections for the
individual finally single party
recording can promote transparency
accountability and Society by recording
your interactions with others you can
ensure that you and the other party are
honest respectful and
responsible you can also avoid
misunderstandings conflicts or disputes
that may arise from miscommunication or
misinterpretation you can also use your
recordings to support claims arguments
opinions to challenge and verify the
claims arguments and opinions of others
for example you can record transactions
with businesses when contracts are
written when warranties are agreed to
and any other issues that would evolve
around that um you can also record
conversations with public officials such
as politicians bureaucrats law
enforcement and Ed these recordings to
hold them accountable to their word and
their promises as you can see single
party recording has many benefits and
advantages for individuals in society it
is allowed in 36 States
currently it can provide personal safety
protection and empowerment and it can
allow journalists and activists to
expose truth in the public enhance
technological landscape and promote
transparency and
accountability thank you for your time
this morning if any has any questions i'
be happy to take
him represent s do you have any con
thank you and thank you for taking my
question do you have any concern about
the potential unintended consequences
like someone using single party
recordings for the purposes of malicious
intent to harm the other
party thank you for your question um it
is allowed currently on 30 states it is
working so I would say there's always
potential for that but I would think the
advantages
outweigh um
representative the um unlike the other
36 States we just passed a
constitutional amendment in New
Hampshire whereby the citizens of New
Hampshire Express their interest in
privacy um how do you think you're your
bill squares with that recent
amendment I would I would think that if
you're an honest person it wouldn't
affect it at all if you're not afraid of
what you say if you keep to your word
then it wouldn't affect it at all thank
you um further
questions okay all right thank you thank
you for your testimony appreciate
it um the chair recognized Mr Binet from
the
ACLU thank you Mr chairman Gil Binet on
behalf of uh the ACLU of New Hampshire
I'm the legal director there I do have
written testimony though I do I am going
to um make some adjustments to it and
send it to the committee probably later
today or Monday um just to reflect uh
some of the comments that have been made
by the uh the sponsor and the intent
behind the sponsor but I this is a bill
that we do oppose uh we oppose on on
privacy grounds listen we think it it's
important to maintain semblance of
privacy particularly where there are
reasonable expectations of privacy in
own homes hotel rooms Etc and so I think
that's a vitally important protection
that we have not only uh in our current
wiretapping statute but as the chairman
mentioned U you know we have
constitutional protections now with
respect to informational privacy so I
think this is really like a a strong New
Hampshire value it is true that New
Hampshire is in the minority of states
that require two-party consent but I
think it is in the minority of States
because it reflects that unique um U
privacy policy importance that we all
have as a state um so and the ACL shares
that view and supports that view uh with
with respect to privacy and thinks uh to
that extent our wiretapping statute
should not change um I do want to get in
just the text of the bill very briefly
uh you know I had a spirited discussion
with the Attorney General's office and
back I think there we we I think we're
both kind of confused about some of the
text of the bill um I myself included um
when you look at just the language I
know that it seems like the intent
behind the bill is to kind of have one
party consent throughout um uh but it it
there there is reasonable expectation of
privacy language in here baked into the
statute so it seems like it's still
would be a crime if there's one party
consent where the person being recorded
had an expectation a reasonable
expectation of Prophecy that's how I I
uh read it and I actually want to be
clear that I think that's actually
already in the law so it is true that
we're a two-party consent state but
there is an exception to two-party
consent um and that's when the person
being recorded does not have a
reasonable expectation of privacy and I
give you like a really good example of
that and it came up in a case about 10
years ago it was an individual recording
um a police officer in wear as that
officer was performing his duties out in
public and of course the officer had not
consented to that um but the court
concluded the district court concluded
there that that that doesn't violate the
wir tab statute because when you look at
section one of the wir tab statute which
defines oral communication um this uh
you know there is kind of you there is
language that says an oral communication
that's covered under the statute is one
where um there's a reasonable
expectation that the communication is
not subject to interception under
circumstances justifying the exception I
think that's legal Leed to say
reasonable expectation of privacy so um
I I want to be very clear that we
already have baked into the statute
protections that allow for recording
where we want government accountability
right where we want to be able to record
public officials where they're
performing their work in public where
there's no reasonable expectation of
privacy there isn't a need there for
two-party consent so I think in New
Hampshire actually though we are in the
minority of States our current law does
a very good job of balancing privacy
rights but also with the need to in
certain circumstances record um when
there's no expectation of privacy
including government officials so um I
think for those reasons um you know we
don't support the bill it either already
does what the sponsors want or or it
goes even further depending how you read
it to ban outright um or or to mandate
in all circumstances one party consent
which we would have serious concerns
with thank you any
questions representative
scitec Mr Vette what about my privacy
right why can't I have something the
size of a pack of cigarettes in my shirt
pocket to record my day for whatever
purpose I want yeah I mean I think that
that would be a good argument if that
went wasn't also impacting other
individuals rights right and I think it
would if that individual being recorded
has no understanding or no um uh has an
expectation of privacy um I think that
person's rights would be impacted by it
and I think what current law is trying
to do are balancing balance those two
things if that person that you're
recording as you're going about your day
doesn't have an expectation of privacy
maybe depending on where you are you
could be out in a in a public place
where other people could hear you um the
wiretap stat statute wouldn't apply um
so I think it really depends on the
circumstance uh because that the
circumstances
matter no further questions thank you
thank you for the uh the accommodation
Mr chairman thank
you chair calls Richard
bolinski good
morning um just to be up front for
because that's how I am I'm actually the
one that asked Ron D to bring this
forward I'm the
constituent the reason I wanted bring
this forward
and you can put amendments in it if you
want to narrow it down a little more is
I've been involved with town lary for a
long time I liveed there I've been there
38 years been in New Hampshire going on
55 I'm 63 years
old and I've had many conversations with
for with Town managers former Town
managers over what's going on in the
town stuff that affects the people of
the town I was also the town treasurer
for three years back in the early
2000s and what they'll tell you in
private is totally different than what
they'll admit to at a public council
meeting and that's an issue it's you
know there's money issues involved
there's just a lot of issues where
they'll deny they even had the
conversation with you I've followed the
law not recorded those if you say a
couple times I said I want to record
this and like well we're not having this
conversation if it was narrowed down to
elected public officials or dealing with
a company I recently had an instance
before this um after this was put in I
had to have a refrigerator repair done
on my refrigerator they come in they
diagnosed it $1,300 it didn't fix it
they did the same thing over again
didn't fix it they finally said we don't
want to do this anymore we're going to
give you your money
back now they're saying they're not
going to do anything they haven't given
your money back I could have recorded
that this we didn't say that yeah you
did my wife heard it I heard it that's
the type stuff I'm looking at I
understand the Privacy within your
home but you know the good can outweigh
the bad on this in my opinion 35 States
plus the District of Columbia don't have
a problem with the worlds haven't ended
uh you can go to just there's
a they have the uh requirements within
those States you know maybe it's
something to look at and we have to
implement some of their requirements May
some may be good some may be bad
somewhere people have to be accountable
for not telling the truth that's my
whole thing about this is could it hurt
in some ways yeah I guess it
could but does the good outweigh the bad
I think it can I don't think you'll
actually have to end up recording a lot
of times because just the fact that
people know you can now do it they may
say I better tell the truth or they just
won't have the conversation with you at
all you have to look what goes on in our
town it happens all the time and every
time I try to bring it up in public so
the public knows oh we never had that
conversation what are you talking you
weren't in my office this is the type
stuff I'm trying to avoid
so yeah people may not like it but if
you don't lie and you tell the truth
it's not going to be an issue I always
tell tell the truth at least I believe
I'm always telling the truth maybe you
know I'm misinformed on something I
wouldn't say anything here I wouldn't
say in public or in a council meeting
I've been thrown out of Council meetings
for telling the truth and then they look
at the law that I gave them counselor
dun can testify to that and they say oh
yeah he was right where does it startop
where do they where and I know you're
elected officials and I'm sorry to put
it this
way when do we get our rights protected
from people who are put to represent us
we not telling the truth they say one
thing behind closed doors and then in
public they say nope never happened I
think just the I don't want to use the
word threat just the idea that they
could be recorded maybe that will stop
you know maybe the committee takes a you
know I can leave this one copy and it's
online and has all the states that are
and for and you know how they go about
it um do you need to change the wording
as the ASL yeah probably I I can agree
with that I don't care how it's worded
that's up to you people you have to give
the common citizen some more
protection in certain stuff if you want
to say you can't do it in somebody's
home that's fine I'm fine with that but
if it's a company that you're deal in
business with and they're lying to you
or an official we should be protected
Maybe we put some restrictions in it as
to what you can use it
for you know he says there some built in
there already you know the reasonable
you know you know what he was talking
about you know does the average citizen
going to take that to court on their
dime where if it could just be recorded
they don't have to take somebody to
court that's what these towns depend on
there's been many times I've brought
stuff up in the Town Council or the town
manager will say well then take us to
court yeah that's easy for you to say
you're using the taxpayers money
they just did it to the publisher of the
linary times and they lost it cost the
town 15,000 it was so outrageous the
judge made them pay her her fees
too this has to stop that's what they do
they count on you not having the money
to take them to court when they could
just answer the questions I mean I could
go through a lot of examples when
they're talk about you know we don't
have the you don't have the time for
that so that's why I brought it forward
if it needs to be amended adjusted the
I'm fine with that
but there has to be some protection for
people for the average citizen that's
why you're elected 70.5% of the states
includ and the District of Columbia
that's how you get the
36 that's a
70.5% approval if you guys won your
elections by 70.5% you'd be thrilled you
know so that's all I have to say on it
could you uh give that document to the
representative on the end please I'd
appreciate it any questions for the
gentlemen no questions thank you for
your
time the chair recognizes attorney
Steven
Enders good morning Stephen ERS I'm an
assistant County attorney with the marac
county attorney's office I I don't know
if I support this or oppose it
um I I do think that the WAP statute is
is a statute that's sort of ripe for for
Amendment and where we see this in in my
life
is
it whenever someone is about to start a
lawsuit or is going to be the victim of
a crime or that type of thing we always
tell them to document everything and
really the best way to document
something is to record it and everyone
now has a cellphone in their pocket and
has the ability to audio and video
record what's going on so we'll end up
having domestic violence cases where the
the victim of domestic violence will
record what happened and it leaves no
doubt what was said it leaves no doubt
what occurred um the difficulty is that
if that recording was made
surreptitiously or secretly it has the
potential to uh run a foul of the
current wiretap statute we've certainly
had cases where we've had neighbor
disputes where the police tell them
just film what's going on and that way
we'll know exactly what's going on if
this ends up in court and certainly we
had a neighbor that did exactly that uh
filmed himself actually getting
assaulted by his neighbor and the court
said unfortunately under the wiretap
statute I have to keep that out of
evidence because that was IL legally
obtained um that
recording so that's sort of the point of
view we come from is it would be nice to
allow victims of crime or for people in
situations where they're going to end up
in court to be able to record what's
going on so that we know exactly what
was said and exactly what happened um
and the difficulty is again the WAP
statute sometime is implicated by that I
I'm the one that had the conversation
with attorney biset um during the break
and we're not really sure what the the
consequences of this statute would be as
I read it um paragraph one is the
current state of the law um the current
law doesn't use the term expectation of
privacy it uses the term uh having a
reasonable expectation that the
conversation is not subject to
interception I would recommend that the
language mirror what's currently in the
statute because I think expectation of
privacy could be different than an
expectation that something is not
subject to
interception um paragraph 1 a and
paragraph 1 the only only difference I
see between them is the mental state
where it would be a felony if you
willfully intercepted and a misdemeanor
if you knowingly
intercepted um I don't know how you
would knowingly intercept something
without willfully intercepting it so I
think you'd almost always end up in that
that paragraph one felony and then
paragraph 1B as as I interpret that
paragraph and attorney biset I may
disagree on this if one party is aware
that the recording is being made then it
is not illegal to make the recording so
as long as one person there knows it's
being recorded then it wouldn't be
illegal that would certainly solve those
domestic violence victim problems would
solve the the neighborhood dispute
problems but as you heard there's
certainly unintended consequences with
that regarding
uh people's personal privacy so happy to
answer any
questions what how does the the current
state of law impact things like the the
ring video doorbell that that records
people and without their permission
ostensively
so again the the definition of um oral
communication in the current statute
indicates that it's a
communication that you have a reasonable
expectation it's not subject to
interception under circumstances
justifying that
exception I would say in today's world
you're being intercepted almost
constantly I know that I have an iPhone
if I yell out hey Siri I think
everyone's iPhone beeps because my
iPhone is constantly intercepting what
I'm saying waiting to be sort of woken
up
um it's my position that if you're
standing on someone's front porch
you don't have an expectation that
you're not being subject to intercept
there because there's ring cameras
everywhere um you could certainly make
the argument that I had no idea standing
on someone's porch I was being
intercepted but I don't know that that
would necessarily fly in in today's
society thank you further questions
representative
scitech does interception mean recording
no what does interception meanc
interception
means the oral or other acquisition of
or the recording of the contents of any
telecommunication or oral communication
through the use of any electronic
mechanical or other
device so as I read that
definition my phone the oral
interception my phone is constantly
listening to what I'm saying waiting for
me to say certain keywords to sort of
wake it up
so I think my phone even though it's not
recording everything I'm saying is
intercepting everything I'm
saying so while interception includes
recording it's not limited to
recording so interception is broader
than recording absolutely uh I once
heard this said is this true that I
could have a secret camera watching as
long as it's not recording audio under
is that true under the WAP statute that
would be accurate the WAP statute only
deals with audio not
video rep Stone thank you and thank you
for taking my question uh when I look at
this statute it reminds me of an older
time when there was the business of
doing one party consents to get wire
interceptions or uh UC operations and uh
it was explicit that you'd get the
permission to do those through the
Attorney General's office on most
offenses uh I look at this as more of a
step statute for government than for
actual individuals even though actual
individuals could apply and throughout
history as you know and may have
mentioned we've evolved into a different
time so would you in your opinion feel
that this statute might need to be
visited at some point to refresh it to
where we are today absolutely um the
wiretap statute in New Hampshire was
initially adopted I want to say in in
1969 and that was part of it the New
Hampshire wi taps statute is essentially
copied directly from the federal I think
it's the Omnibus crime bill of 1969 is
part three of that and when you when you
think about the technology in 1969 the
WAP statute's really concerned with
essentially like putting alligator clips
on someone's you know phone lines and
somehow listening into their those
conversations it talks about um
switchboard operators it talks about a
number of things um technology obviously
has changed since then and when I look
at you know we I I had a conversation
with another attorney in my office about
whether or not hearing aids that
actually enhance your hearing Beyond
normal level would constitute a
violation of wiretap Statute I think
technically under the current law they
may um but I certainly think it's it's
worth revisiting the WAP statute
especially in light of all the
technology that currently exists thank
you how many prosecutions do you see per
per year roughly if any um for
violations of the wab
statute uh hardly any um it's very
uncommon for us to prosecute someone for
violating the WAP statute where we see
it come up most again is on the victim
or witness side of things where we've
had a victim or witness surreptitiously
recording it we have no interest in
charging this person um but it presents
an obstacle to getting that information
in front of the court does the court
always disallow it or will they allow
the video portion and not the
audio so
there's different judges have
interpreted the statute differently um
there's a provision within the current
wiretap Statute in
570a um which prohibits use
of the intercepted Communication in
court if it would be illegal to uh
distribute
it under the current wiretap statute and
I hope I can explain this there's a
class there's a felony level wir tap
where if nobody has permission
to if no one knows it's being recorded
it's a
felony if one person in the
communication knows it's being recorded
then it ends up being a
misdemeanor so under the felony if
you're secretly recording a conversation
between two people and neither one of
them are aware you're committing a
felony also under the felony statute if
you use that conversation um or I don't
know the exact word that's used in the
statute but essentially if you use that
conversation distribute that
conversation it's an additional felony
so it's a felony to make it and then
it's another felony use it under the
misdemeanor section of the statute again
if two people are talking and one person
knows they're being recorded we're in
the misdemeanor section of the statute
it's a misdemeanor to make the recording
but there's no additional crime to use
the recording or distribute the
recording the way the exceptions to the
statutes the prohibition on using it
says if it were illegal to distribute it
it can't be used in court some judges
have interpreted that to mean only that
felony level um intercept so if one
person knew about it you could still use
it in court some judges have interpreted
it more broadly to mean any wiretap you
can't use in court and we've seen other
judges as you've said indicate I'll show
the video portion but take the audio
portion out of it so no Cas has made it
to the Supreme Court no okay all right
representative sake thank you and thank
you for taking my question um I have a
similar question to what I asked the
sponsor of the bill which is um do you
see potential for um unintended
consequences especially in the case of
perhaps a domestic abuser who um might
use something like this to force someone
to record something without their
knowledge or might abuse something in
that way yeah absolutely I think there's
potential unintended consequences of
allowing people to record essentially
everything that's going on around
them thank you do you see um some sort
of language that could go into an
amendment that would help um prevent
that type of unintended
consequence um potentially I I
think listening to the sponsor and the
individual before me who spoke about
this bill their intent is
essentially um to keep businesses
politicians that type of thing on the up
and up my concern is really um people
documenting crimes whether they be the
victim or or a witness to a crime so I
think that you could certainly write an
amendment to the wiretap statute that
would allow for people to document what
they reasonably believe is a crime to
either provide that material to the
police or a court or or that type of
thing I think that would address some of
my concerns I don't know that that would
address the concerns of the the bill
sponsor essentially to keep businesses
um or politicians on on the up and up
and that I'm sure you could could try
and craft another amendment that would
allow you know the recording of public
officials or the recording of people
during official
business represent Stone thank you and
once again thank you for taking my
question I know we've seen and heard of
a lot of uh anybody recording under I
believe it's the the Auditors the
freedom Auditors that go around
videotaping uh your local town office
your cour houses that kind of thing
wouldn't they actually be already
covered if it's in in public a
absolutely and I I know that
the I know the individuals that I've run
into are open in notoriously recording
you and open in not iously recording
someone does not run a foul with the wi
tap statute thank
you her
n thank you Mr chair and thanks for
taking my question um I'm wondering you
know especially when you're recording
things what you said was you know it's
the best way to document uh what
somebody says my question and I'm going
to put it in the context of another bill
that we had just as an example um around
oh around well what what we essentially
called it shorthand is fighting words MH
um and the way that would be a
provocation so if you started recording
after just using that example cuz it's
fresh on our minds if you started
recording after that kind of um
instigating Point um are those kind of
things you know if something like this
were um implemented would that be taken
into consideration of of how it might
have been um not the whole story yeah
and again under current law if you were
sort of secretly recording the fighting
words it would be a misdemeanor because
it would be that one party knows one
party doesn't
know under this bill as I read it it
wouldn't be a crime because one party
knows and as long as one party knows it
no longer fits into the the wiretap
statute thank you I I think my I should
have said it a little more clear oh I'm
sorry can I follow up okay um is that
you know would would the point at which
it was started be taken into
consideration If This Were uh used as
evidence um again someone with the with
the idea that I just wonder about it
being um not the whole story right
exactly it's certainly I think that a
court has the ability to limit evidence
coming in um if it has the potential to
mislead in the sense that it's it's not
telling the whole
story is um in your opinion is there not
potential for provocation of tape and
then result on tape
for example in the cases of of uh
spouses um divorce proceedings um
someone saying you know what you're this
record now you get the results
back no I think that's absolutely a
potential and as we were saying I think
that comes
into um you know the court being able to
to limit what what they're looking at
but we have we have certainly had cases
where
I know I'm aware of at least one case
where we had a person who I would
consider the abusive
partner um who is holding his phone
going I'm afraid of you stop hitting me
like you know and trying to record that
to make it seem as though he's the one
who was actually in Peril when he was
not represent
scitech would you give an example of a
felony uh inter reception because you
said if no party is aware of it and I
understand that um so if I had see for
example there's a conference room in
this building where you guys you know
have private
conversations and I sneak into that
conference room and I put my phone in
there and I put my phone on record and I
put it under my you know a jacket or a
hat and I leave and I know that you're
about to step into that conference room
and have a private conversation with
someone and you then go in that
conference room you have a conversation
you leave I go back in afterwards and
retrieve my phone that would be an
example of a a felony violation of the
wiretap
statute there be no further questions
thank you for your testimony thank you
anyone else wishing to testify on this
bill who hasn't testified seeing none I
here but I close public
hearing and we will now
open
the public hearing on House Bill 1217
and I invite the prime sponsor to
introduce the
bill
1217 oh this is
um for the um for the committee what
before we get started on the the
previous Bill 1039 I making a
subcommittee on the subcommittee will be
Representatives um Manion Balden Murphy
and
tenar on the last bill we just heard
reference to wippa making a subcommittee
representative Stone salig Newell and
janen for um representative Manion and
representative salig please uh within
two weeks if we could thank
you thank you Mr chairman
I'm I'm Barry fauler I represent Swansea
enrichment
uh we have four covered bridges in
Swansea and then the town next to to us
has two more all of which carry traffic
uh this bill is a is an attempt to help
preserve those historic covered bridges
um I know other people are going to be
talking about the value of these Bridges
to the state uh me talk a little bit
about what the bill does um as you might
know right now we um Pro prohibit towns
and the state from General video
recording of traffic there are a few
exceptions made such as uh toll barriers
where it's required for security
purposes Etc and we're proposing to add
one more exception which is to monitor
historic covered bridges for the purpose
of identifying the cause of damage to
those bridges and and have you know
Safeguard in here that that be the only
purpose they could be uh collected for
and any recording not needed for that
purpose would be erased on a regular
basis um I can tell you that I live
about a quarter mile from one of the
bridges I think is probably the the
bridge that handles the most regular
traffic at least among the one lane
historic bridges in the
state um it gets banged up regularly I
think there there are three separate um
incidents of damage to the bridge since
last
summer uh it's a burden on the town to
repair those it uh detracts from the
attractiveness I know we have tourists
come up every day to take pictures of
the bridge we have bus loads of people
come up especially in the bridge to I
mean in the in the fall to to seagar
Bridges I mean it's a it's an important
resource uh I find it disturbing to see
the degree of damage I mean a lot of it
is cosmetic uh but
um it's it's it's nonetheless
uh an issue that we all should be
concerned about even if we don't have a
bridge in our town so uh I I try to have
this carefully crafted so that it would
respect the Privacy rights of those who
drive their bridge and don't cause
damage um or who you know stop and
Report the the damage so that the that
you know
the bills can be sent to the right place
uh but I think it's something it's
important to do to kind of prevent this
sort of ongoing damage I mean it's it's
it's frequent in my town
anyway
um ready to answer any questions if if
there are any thank you um is most of
the damage vandalism or is it from
Vehicles Bridge from my personal
observation I know uh that Town
Administrator from Swansea is here but
he may be able to give you a little more
comprehensive but from my observation it
is vehicle
strikes uh
either uh trucks that are too tall and
they take out some of the FAS or siding
at the top or somebody pulling a trailer
and they pull too close to the edge and
clip off a corner uh again what you can
see is sort of the Cosmetic I mean
they're you know these boards here that
kind of get ripped off easily and get
replaced fairly easily uh I think the
other I think we want to have a
disincentive for people to drive over
Bridges with vehicles that aren't
suitable a lot of these bridges are
weighted limited by weight certainly by
height and
uh and every time you have a overweight
vehicle go over the bridge there's some
unseen damage too so to the extent that
we can create a disincentive to people
to kind of try to sneak across because
nobody's going to see or if they
accidentally hit the bridge and then
figure nobody's looking so I'm taking
off I think that uh the uh the
disincentive effect of this would be
would be valuable on its
own represent Manion thank you and thank
you for taking my question uh is it not
true that under that statute there's
already a provision to allow that for
certain bridges that are named uh not
wooden not wooden bridges but certain
list of bridges right there are a number
of listed listed exceptions um so this
would apply to there are 58 bridges in
the state covered bridges in the state
about 40 of which regularly carry
traffic so you know again it would be up
to the municipality or the state whoever
is responsible for the bridge whether
they want to monitor it or not but it
would include that whole group of U of
bridges in the in the exception okay so
you're looking to expand it to to these
historic
Bridges historic covered bridges right
thank
you further questions thank than give
your testimony
thank uh chair calls representative
rhods thank you Mr chairman for the
record I'm representative J for roess I
represent chesher County District 17
which is wi Winchester Richmond Swansea
Troy and Fitz William I do share the
towns of Swansea and Richmond with
representative that just presented this
bill and I pretty much agree with
everything he said uh the one thing I
did see as of about 15 minutes ago just
double checking to make sure that I
wasn't incorrect is my understanding
that the state of New Hampshire has 70
covered bridges with with which 58 of
those have an actual state ID state ID
number um there are a total of six cover
bridges in the two towns that I
represent and because these bridges are
historic tourist attraction the towns go
to Great Lengths to make sure that these
bridges are held at a standard a little
bit above the norm when there's Damage
Done to these Bridges the state doesn't
take responsibility to fix that damage
the towns are responsible for that and
it's thousands of dollars per incident
unfortunately because the state doesn't
help if there is a bridge that is closed
for any period of time that greatly
affects the Commerce in that town
overall with the entire State um
I would ask that the committee please
support this bill especially because the
people from my town are here and that
would be great um there's any questions
I'm happy to take
them see no questions thank you thank
you Mr
chair chair calls representative
Margaret
dry
good
afternoon thank you Mr chairman
committee uh for the record I'm
representative Margaret dry serving
Sullivan district 7 uh includes the
towns of Newport Unity Charlestown
planfield and Cornish the home of the
iconic Cornish Windsor covered bridge
over the Connecticut
River uh this bill is a companion to my
Bill H Bill 1457 that raises the amount
charged for damages to wooden covered
bridges uh this is a necessary bill this
one here because a good number of
incidents that cause damage to cover
bridges are hit and
run extensive police time has to be
devoted to tracking down the vehicle and
many times it is never found yet the
damage that's done to the bridge still
has to be repaired in a small town like
Cornish this is a costly process both in
terms of police time and Bridge
repair the requirements set forth in
this bill are as careful as possible
about privacy the use is restricted to
one purpose the time the video is kept
is the time needed to determine if it
will be necessary to pursue charges and
unneeded videos are erased within seven
days um this morning I got a message
from the um Cornish police chief that
I'd like to read to you uh I'm Doug
Hackett the chief of police for the town
of Cornish where I've been employed
since 1988 I stand in support of hb1
1217 the Cornish Police Department
routinely responds to one of its four
covered bridges to take reports of past
t damage to the bridge each time the
officer arrives to find shattered wood
small pieces of cars and routinely no
drivers or vehicles around it becomes
very frustrating to see our historic
Bridges routinely damaged by oversized
vehicles and the drivers get away with
it leaving the cost of the repairs in
the taxpayers hands I'm a strong
advocate for placing cameras on the
bridges in some in the case of the
Cornish Windsor historic Covered Bridge
damage is routinely called in in a
timely fashion but some of the smaller
Bridges may result in a notification a
day or two later with that in mind I
would not encourage short retention
spans for the data I would think
ensuring that we had at least 15 to 30
days of data would be imperative please
join me in supporting hb1 1217 and
showing support for protection of our
historic covered
bridges um I don't have any problem with
extending the time period um or keeping
the bill as written and um I am asking
you to please help protect our historic
icons and support this bill and I'm open
to any questions thank you thank you see
no questions thank you for your
testimony thank you Micha
chair calls Michael
branley good afternoon thank you for
having me uh my name is Michael branley
I am the Town Administrator in the town
of Swansea as has been mentioned uh
Swansea has several covered bridges um a
bridge is on our town seal and
letterhead the message on our website
has at times said Swansea bridging
tradition and change uh historically
when the Slate Bridge was the victim of
arson and burned down in the 1990s
voters of the Town funded a new kind of
uh reproduction cover bridge that looked
like the old one and in 2022 this town
spent nearly $60,000 to paint the
exterior of the Thompson Covered Bridge
so needless to say uh cover bridges are
important to swansea's history identity
and sense of community we take their
preservation
seriously uh many cover bridges in New
Hampshire are on Scenic back roads and
see low levels of traffic other than
local traffic and tourists taking Scenic
pictures in the fall I expect most of
these Bridges largely Faire okay and do
not receive much much damage from
traffic um local traffic knows uh best
what what vehicles belong on them and
three of swansea's uh cover Bridges meet
this description and and don't have
serious issues but our exception is the
Crescent Bridge which representative of
funner mentioned uh it's on Sawyer
crossing road which is an unnumbered
State Highway and one of the few primary
routes from Swansea to the city of Keane
uh the Crescent Bridge handles thousands
of vehicles per day most of which are
cars pickup trucks SUVs they yield to
traffic on the bridge and cross one at a
time unfortunately all too com all too
common are box trucks trucks
recreational vehicles commercial
vehicles and other vehicles that are too
heavy or too tall to safely cross the
bridge we know how most of them get
their they're following a GPS they
disregard the warning signs or they're
just plain not paying attention some of
them I'm sure are oblivious of the
impending obstacle until they hit the
bridge others uh are observed kind of
stopping before seeming to calculate
whether they're going to make it or not
and then uh and then they go for it some
of them make it through uncap
unscathed and some of them do not uh
it's the ones who make it through and
damage the bridge but are able to
continue that this legislation uh would
help address so communities could
identify and hold them
accountable uh as also been mentioned so
far Swansea has been relatively
fortunate and most of our damage has
been superficial and not structural but
other towns have not been so lucky and
have seen their cover Bridges uh reive
significant damage that forced their
closure for uh long-term instances
even relatively minor damage requires
the bridge to be closed to traffic for
repairs and when an insurance company is
not involved the town's not going to
incur the expense of hiring a contractor
um so we use it with DPW staff which is
already over taxed and takes away from
their other duties uh if this
legislation is approved word would get
out that cameras are monitoring the
bridges when they get damaged and I'm
confident that uh the damage to cover
Bridges throughout the state would be
reduced as has been mention the statute
already outlined some exemptions for uh
the blanket uh inability of towns to
serve surveil on public roads I do agree
with the sentiment behind the statute
that doesn't and do not think that
cameras should be common on public roads
but I feel uh that historic cover
Bridges should be Exempted so New
Hampshire can preserve them for the
generations to
come representative
Jam thank you thank you uh something you
said in your statement kind of clicked
with me and I have to ask this question
I'm so sorry it's pressing you said if
this law is passed it would it would
notify everybody that um this that we're
surveilling the bridges for
damage what are your thoughts on
requiring a sign 100 ft down the road
from the from the bridge saying video
recording in progress I would have no
issue with
that
see no further questions thank you for
your testimony I also have testimony
from a resident that I'd like to Sure
pass it down to the thing is there
anyone else here wishing to testify on
this bill who hasn't testified on this
bill yet seeing no one I he by closes
public
hearing there's my list of
bills
and hereby open the public hearing on
House Bill 1260 and invite the sponsor
to introduce their
bill good afternoon thank you Mr
chairman
for the record I'm representative
Jennifer rhs I represent Winchester with
Winchester Richmond Swansea Troy and
Fitz William still District
17 I in front of you this morning to
present legislation that will hopefully
fix RSA
6449 from being used as a loophole in
prosecution for of perpetrators that
knowingly and willingly violate a
Minor's privacy only being charged with
a misdem meanor crime instead of a
felony offense that we would see and any
other Child Protection
Law because RSA
6449 does not take the age of a victim
into
account when a person violates a child's
privacy in their own home in a bathroom
a locker room or any other place that
any reasonable person would consider to
be
private that results in that person that
secretly recorded a child only being
charged with a misdemeanor
consequence it would be the same
consequence is if a person secretly
recorded a person in their kitchen
instead of a child taking a
shower sadly this is happening in the
state of New Hampshire and it has
happened more than
once it's very unfortunate that you will
hear this afternoon from a mother that
is living this terrorizing account every
single day crimes against children are
considered more heinous due to the vul
vulnerability of the victim in the
long-lasting such offenses can have and
most often on the child's physical and
emotional
well-being we need to recognize that
sexual exploitation of a minor is
adequately addressed in the law and
place a higher moral value on protecting
those who are defenseless and unable to
comprehend that their V vulnerability is
being
targeted we have already addressed
violations of privacy and we have we
have addressed child
pornography please let us make this the
year that we pass House Bill 1260 and
make it clear that New Hampshire will
not tolerate nor condone this Behavior
en close the loophole by adequately
addressing the seriousness of the
offense as the disturbing sex crime that
this
is thank you Mr
chairman thank you I just have a quick
question it seems to me you've been
working on this issue for years um is
this the first bill that we've seen on
this or um I I recall us working on this
uh previous years
I don't know how far how far back you're
meaning this is my second term I do know
that we addressed the Privacy Law which
we passed and unfortunately I think what
has happened is this has been an
unattended con consequence of not
addressing the age of the minor so
instead of this being charged as child
pornography which is what everybody
thought when this first came up every
single person I talk to every single
person I talk to about co-sponsoring
along with self the first thing was
isn't that child pornography but because
it was secretly recorded it was not
considered to be child pornography
because it was not shared it was not
considered to be the sex crime that it
is so
unfortunately the way that the
information was gathered is the way it
had to be prosecuted and obviously um
attorney Enders is here and he can
explain how this law has been affected
and been used as a loophole I certainly
am not the one to explain that in depth
thank you see no questions thank you for
oh representative
M so basically this this bill is an
enhanced penalty if the victim is a
child yes you could say that okay thank
you thank you for your bill thank you Mr
chair chair calls Jay
Larson that's Jay lson right
rookie mistake thank you for taking my
testimony um I am here just on behalf of
myself and the community of children
around the state of New Hampshire that
have voices that are not being heard um
this bill addresses the fact that a
minor can be unwillingly uh video taped
in the privacy of their own home and
their perpetrator is now charged with a
a misdemeanor the message that this
sends to our children is yeah you're
important but not that important it's a
it's a slap on the wrist it's something
that you know a misdemeanor is something
that basically says you did something
wrong but not that wrong and so I think
for the psychological health and
well-being of these children who are
having to go through this process to
realize that perhaps a very trusted
person within their inner Circle within
their family has violated their most
fundamental personal right to privacy
you know whether it's in in the in a
restroom when they're taking a shower to
say that this is a misdemeanor that it's
just you know well we're going to give
you a smack on the wrist and send you on
your way you're not listed as a sex
offender you are in no way protecting
children moving forward from being
subjected to this person's bad behavior
and so I think in support of this
current bill
uh it really takes it to a level of
seriousness that says to the public if
you're a victim we care about you if
you're a victim we're going to support
you and we're going to have something of
a penalty that represents the severity
of what has happened to you and I think
for perpetrators it says you can't get
away with utilizing technology to your
advantage to these unwitting children I
think part of the problem is our laws
haven't kept up with our technology you
know we have so many ways of doing
horrible things things to people
photographically you know through video
through taping to invade our privacy and
I think that this bill at least protects
the children who are at the the you know
have the least ability to be aware of
their environment to be looking you know
is there a is there a red flashing light
that's watching me following me you know
so if if you know we have to address
this on a different level for adults you
know so be it but at least for the
children's sake I think that this bill
is incredibly important sends a strong
message that you matter your your safety
your innocence they matter so with that
um I don't know that I can answer any
questions but I'd be happy to thank you
see no questions thank you thank you for
your
time chair calls Pamela
Kylie
uh good afternoon uh Mr chair and
members of the committee again my name
is Pamela kyg and I'm the public policy
specialist for the Coalition uh who
represents uh our 12 community- based
crisis centers and survivors in the
state I'm here in support of hb1 1260
today legislation that seeks to address
a dangerous loophole in the violation of
privacy statute um most people in New
Hampshire believe that a person who
surreptitiously videotapes or uses a
cell phone to record someone in a public
bathroom would be charged with a felony
um if you open a web page to Google and
enter into a search bar the terms video
recording in public bathroom you will
probably see very comfortable amount of
videos where people committed crimes a
violation of privacy in New Hampshire
however because of our statutory
framework these people who may have
captured hundreds of children in
bathrooms can only be charged with a
misdemeanor if law enforcement and
prosecutors cannot improve
distribution um I just kind of want to
walk through a couple of scenarios I
know it was touched on a little bit in
the introduction of this bill and we had
a pretty lengthy conversation about wire
tapping which is one of the examples
that I'm going to uh address today um so
uh I just wanted to walk um take a
moment to walk through kind of where
filming a naked child in a is a felony
in New Hampshire so if it's distributed
um if there is sound like um the wiet
tapping statute um and if the child is
engaged in sexual explicit conduct
however what this bill is addressing is
the account is um the situation that is
not accounted for where a perpetrator
films the child does not distribute the
video has no recorded sound and the
child is not touching themselves
sexually this scenario is only a
misdemeanor for the first offense this
means that people can secretly record
children and face very little
consequence this scenario is real and as
you've heard this morning happens more
than I think we would like to realize in
New Hampshire um and many families are
often horrified that the crimes
committed against their children has
such a little consequence um so we
really ask the committee to urgently
address this loophole today um again as
mentioned this is addressing a small um
a small part of RSA 6449 the violations
of privacy statute and just making a
very explicit carve out for those under
the age of 18 um we know that violations
of privacy are not just about peeping
into a window it's recognizing that
these crimes can have lasting impacts on
the emotional and physical well-being of
a victim especially children um and just
in conclusion um priv uh privacy
violations are not victimless crimes and
offenders who commit these acts have
often impacted countless victims
families and communities these crimes
not just violate a child child's privacy
but their sense of Safety and Security
within their own home and Beyond um so I
would just ask you all to please
consider supporting this bill and help
end um this form of child exploitation
in our state thank you so
much thank you questions representative
scitec you said you said that in your
testimony that uh distribution may be
hard to prove but if you got it on the
Internet isn't that distribution so yeah
um and I know that there are a couple of
folks that can speak more specifically
to the nuances of the law um and I'll be
passing around a chart that kind of very
carefully articulates um kind of how um
this bill has an inadvertent loophole
that I don't think anyone intended to
have in this um in when it you know in
the statute so in violations of privacy
in the situation um that we were trying
to describe someone did took a video in
like you know someone could take a video
in a bathroom or another private space
of a child who is not wearing clothes
who is not doing anything sexually
explicit but it is for sexual
gratification the violations of privacy
statute is trying to address those
situations and so someone can have this
video and not distribute it and it's
just a misdemeanor so it it can't be
charged under any other Statute in the
law I hope that clarified things and not
muddled
things see no further questions thank
you the chair calls Anna
Martin
okay
I'm gonna read Anna's testimony on
behalf of her today if that's
okay good morning chairman Roy and
members of the committee my name is Anna
Martin I'm here to speak in support of
hb1
1260 this bill is extremely important to
me thank you for the opportunity to
speak to that
the unthinkable happened to my daughter
a man that we both trusted had been
filming her a child in our family
bathroom capturing every part of her
body this went on for years without
either of us
knowing until she caught him and bravely
came forward I was devastated to learn
what had happened and outraged when I
found out that the punishment for this
crime of secretly recording a child in a
bathroom was was a
misdemeanor I continue to be so upset at
what happened and the lack of
accountability has made the whole
situation even worse it is absolutely
disturbing that such a sickening crime
would only be a Class A Miss demeanor in
the state of New Hampshire with no
requirement to register as a sex
offender while very little Justice was
served for my daughter I want to see
that anyone else out there gets more
Justice than we had and that individuals
who sexually exploit minors get the
punishment they deserve I've been
working with the New Hampshire Coalition
against Domestic and Sexual Violence to
introduce legislation that would
increase the penalty to a felony charge
for the invasion of
privacy the innocence of a child should
be protected at all costs I didn't know
there was a monster living under my roof
for years this hor this whole ordeal has
been EX extremely
horrifying due to the inadequacy of the
current law the man who sexually
exploited my daughter only served 2
months out of two years in
jail what other means are out there to
prevent him from doing this again to
someone else's
child when our children come forward and
ask for help we must believe them we
also have an obligation to protect them
against this type of abuse how am I
supposed to adequately protect my
daughter when there is not an adequate
system in place to proberly hold the
perpetrator
accountable while this legislation can't
undo the harm that was caused to my
family it can help ensure moving forward
people who abuse children in New
hampture are held responsible I urge you
to support this bill and to make sure
children everywhere like my daughter are
not taken advantage
of thank you for your testimony this
morning thank
you there'll be no
questions the chair calls Lieutenant
Tamara
Hester good morning Mr chair members of
the committee my name is Tamara Hester I
am a lieuten with the New Hampshire
State Police I'm currently the commander
of the special investigations unit uh
where we work closely with the New
Hampshire internet crimes against
children task force we are an affiliate
member where we primarily investigate
the child the exploitation of children
based on Nick MC cyber tips as well as
reports that come in from individuals um
such as Mrs Martin who just
testified um so current state current
New Hampshire state law has the same
penalty across the board regardless of
age of the victim under 6449 with this
proposed addition it will further
protect minors who are being violated
and exploited this type of crime can
occur anywhere by both strangers and
individuals known to the victim um many
times this happens with inhome
offenders the material is often being
retained for sexual gratification and
therefore constantly revictimized
individuals this amendment will allow
law enforcement a mechanism to charge
individuals with a felony who are
unlawfully recording miners while they
were in a private place and protecting
the privacy of their bodies while they
are unknowingly being
violated violations of an individual's
privacy have long-lasting and
irreparable effects on a minor without
dissemination or publication the crime
remains a
misdemeanor crimes such as this go hand
inand with other crimes such as this the
threat of disseminating the material as
well as extortion it's imperative that
individuals are held accountable for
their actions and we continue to protect
child
victims and I also just wanted to touch
on one of the other um the testimony or
the question that was asked about um the
definition of uh child sexual abuse
material um so there's a very strict
definition of child sexual abuse
material as uh articulated in 649a to um
and this would actually basically cover
the offenses that may not meet those
elements in terms of um under 649a it's
luden lascivious uh exhibition of the uh
butex or genitalia as well as there's
some some additional language that goes
in there um as mentioned by uh the
Hampshire Coalition there are certain
crimes such as just individuals being in
the new that may not fall into the
definition of 649a but would fall into
the uh 6449
statute anybody representative
scitec this may not be answerable either
by you or Mr Andrew Andrew but I'm
amazed to hear and maybe you had in your
testimony a reason why he only got two
months was there some I you think the
Judge would have done everything he
possibly could to this to the
perpetrator I can't speak to that that
particular case because I'm not familiar
with it but um often times what happens
is though it sounds like he may have
been sentenced to more he probably
received time off for in prison or jail
what would have been considered good
behavior representative Pratt all just
one quick question please um if a person
does this more than once is the crime a
penalty more if they've done it more
than once or if they just done it once
is the same
crime it sounds like occurred over a
long period of time so would that be a a
worse penalty than uh just a onetime
offense seems though it would be
compounded uh yes sir it is actually
considered under the current statute
under paragraph six states that a um
second or subsequent offense under
paragraphs 1 through 3A would be
considered class B felony class B
felony represent wheeler thank you Mr
chairman so following up on
representative Pratt's
question how in the scenario that
someone is doing this for two years is
that not is that not considered a
subsequent offense if someone is doing
this repeatedly over the course of two
years and then they they would not be
charged with the class B felony under
that case subsequent offense generally
speaking means that they would have had
to been convicted of a first offense
right I
see representative Stone thank you and
thank you for taking my question
Lieutenant can you give us some
background on how this material is used
for extortion that you've seen during
your career yes
so cyber crime as as everyone knows is
not limited specifically to to this type
of material but it is specifically used
in order to it's uh it's actually
terminology now it's called sextortion
so if an individual possesses an image
or a video of someone that they think
that can they can gain either some sort
of financial gain or coer a victim into
maybe um producing more material that is
often how it is utilized to ex extort
them so for example we've seen cases
where um a suspect will
if it if it occurs through some sort of
online platform they will uh continue to
ask for money so it might start at a
small amount and then it will continue
to the amount will get larger and larger
and larger and they will threaten to
disseminate to either family or friends
or or
schoolmates thank you
yes see no further questions thank you
for your um representative man thank you
Mr sh one question so I this is
increasing the the penalty to class B
for this violation according to the
statute of second offense would also be
a Class B would it what are your
thoughts on making a second Offense for
this certain chapter this certain
section A Class a
felony I I think that would be
appropriate thank you
yes thank you for your testimony thank
you the chair calls uh attorney
Enders
good afternoon Stephen Andrew I'm an
assistant County attorney in marac
County um I'm a prosecutor I've been a
prosecutor for over 20 years I do
support this legislation and the marac
county attorney's office supports this
legislation uh essentially this doesn't
create a new crime it creates an
increased penalty when
the the perpetrator knows or should know
that the person um they're recording as
a
child prior to 2024 all violation
privacy was a misdemeanor last year uh
thankfully the legislature did pass a
second offense being being a
felony but
unfortunately I
was I got asked about Miss Martin's case
essentially was given that scenario and
was shocked when and uh when I looked at
this and said I I think that's a
misdemeanor and I know a number of other
prosecutors we all sort of racked our
brains to try and find a felony there
and we we couldn't find one um a as was
indicated it doesn't necessarily fit
into child sexual abuse images because
um just changing your clothes or taking
a shower isn't sexually explicit conduct
where the dissemination part fit in was
under 6449 a the non-consensual
dissemination of private sexual images
which is sort of colloquially the
revenge porn statute if you have a nude
photograph of someone and you distribute
it without their permission that
potentially is a felony under that
statute but in this case we didn't have
dissemination so it didn't fit into that
statute either what I like about the
language in this bill is that it really
focuses on what the perpetrator is doing
in terms of where they're hiding this
camera and and I think that's an
important thing to to keep in mind when
I think about um you know I think about
like a a a Walmart or a Target or some
type of department store and someone
hiding a camera in there and certainly
there's there's adult dressing rooms in
those stores and I think hiding a camera
in a in an adult dressing room is is bad
don't get me wrong but there's also a
children's section of those stores and I
think if you're hiding a camera in the
children's dressing
rooms that sort of implicates a whole
new level of you know of perhaps
sickness on the part of the person doing
it and I think that this bill
appropriately would make that a class B
felony I'm happy to answer any
questions representative
Murray thank you Mr chair I'm I'm
reading the rsay that this is changing
so I'm not sure if my concern is is um
valid or not but basically if there were
to be high schoolers you know filming a
Tik Tok or something while they're at
school in the locker room or something
is that going to put them at risk of a
class B
felony
if the statute now has installs or uses
a device well I think if high school
students are filming within the locker
room where people have an expectation of
privacy I think that certainly would run
a fowl of the statute as it's currently
written and if they know that there's
children in that locker room then it
would be a
felony thank you represent Stone just to
clarify that felony if the individual
was under the age of 18 would be treated
as a juvenile justice correct it it
wouldn't be an adult it would go through
the juvenile process juvenile process
corre
than
and Anders would it not be incumbent
upon the schools to have a policy of no
making Tik Tok videos in the in the
school dressing
room
um yeah I mean I think that's that's
common sense and I think it implicates a
a a bigger issue of um people under 18
memorializing um perhaps other people
under 18's nudity or sexual
activity representative s
thank you um and thank you for taking my
question attorney Anders just to clarify
something that you brought up so you
talked about putting a camera for
example in a dressing room in a
department store um and I think about my
own children who by 13 no longer fit in
the clothes in the children's section
and therefore we're changing in what
would I guess you would consider the
adult section right but really is for
anyone over the age of 10 um so if
they're in the section that but by your
interpretation if this were enacted if
they're in the same dressing room that
I'm
using and and this camera has been set
up surreptitiously to tape
them is it would they be subject to a a
felony or to a misdemeanor because
there're still minors who are being
subjected to the same abuse it's just
that they needed to go to a more age
appropriate location to change the way
the statute is is currently proposed we
would have to show that the person
who put the camera there knows or um
should know that the person entitled to
privacy therein is a
child so if you sort of accidentally
catch a child on your your secret hidden
camera that wouldn't necessarily run a
foul of this bill as it's currently
written so for clarity if someone put a
camera hoping to catch generally
speaking women in the in the changing
room and they happen to catch a child
they'd still be charged with the felony
because of the child is that not correct
or do they you have to prove intent to
catch a child correct you'd have to
prove intent to catch the child I see if
you had a you know it's an adult locker
room say where you had no knowledge that
children were ever using it it would
still be a misdemeanor even if a child
happened to to be there under this
language um you could certainly amend it
to make it so that any you know
surreptitiously recorded video that
happens to get child is a
felony okay thank further questions um
representative Reed thank you Mr
chairman one point I could think of if
of a child being in an adult changing
room is parents will go in with their
kids as they change all the way on
through so there should be no um
distinction right between
where it should just be a given that
they're going to get no matter where it
is right I think you can certainly craft
a statute that says if you um are
surreptitiously recording and you catch
a child it's a felony okay thank
you under the current statute um is
catching an adult or child either or
does it require registration on the sex
offender
I believe it does I'm not 100% sure I
can check for it if you is it explicit
in the new Statute in the proposed bill
I didn't notice it
uh just look up the do you recommend
that if it's not that it should
be I certainly don't think it would
necessarily be a bad idea if you were
convicted of a felony level violation of
privacy that you have to register as a
sex offender good thank you um see
nothing further thank you thank you is
there anyone else wishing to testify on
this bill or is not testified seeing
none I'm closing the public
hearing um we will be on lunch break
until
1:30
what
what yeah yeah we're going to be here
for quite a while so we need to eat
lunch
e
dis
spons thank you representative Roy and
members of the committee uh for the
record my name is representative David
Muse I represent Portsmouth Newcastle
and
Newington a few years ago in 2016 New
Hampshire joined a growing number of
states when we finally criminalized
image-based sexual abuse which is more
commonly known as revenge porn section
644 4 colon 9 of New Hampshire law makes
the non-consensual dissemination of
images involving another person's sexual
activity or intimate Parts a class B
felony what my bill does is bring the
statute up to date by closing some
loopholes the technology along with the
very worst in human nature have
created first of all the bill expands
the defin definition of disseminate from
Real World things like printing
publishing and Manufacturing to the
virtual world so it specifically
includes posting or sharing an image
electronically while it can be argued
that the current definition includes
electronic posting and sharing it's not
in there so it can also be argued that
it doesn't this small change would
remove the ambiguity and would clarify
how the law should
work the second thing that HB 1319 does
is criminalize the act of making and
sharing non-consensual deep fake porn
videos Deep fakes are visual content
that's created using artificial
intelligence
technology this technology does not
require a room-sized computer uh today
it's actually available to anybody with
a
smartphone it doesn't require any
special skills or any special training
some of these apps can realistically
swap the face of a celebrity or a porn
star with the face of a victim others
use deep learning algorithms that can be
trained to remove clothes from images or
videos of women and replace them with
images of other people's naked body
parts the results are extremely
realistic and are increasingly
indistinguishable from the real
thing there are also deep fake creators
uh of content who take commissions and
who charge as little as $30 to
seamlessly uh insert the facial features
uh uh of a person uh onto the body of a
porn star uh or the facial features onto
anybody that they actually feel like
targeting and that can include uh your
24-year-old daughter uh who's uh in the
process of searching for a job whose new
employer might be Googling her name on
the Internet uh these videos are
actually showing up in things like
Google search
results they can be used to extort money
from a victim to rec a reputation or
just for the simple thrill that comes to
those who enjoy ruining other people's
lives in 2023 the New Hampshire Supreme
Court ruled that deep vake computer
images can constitute harassment in the
case SD versus NB the offender uploaded
a profile of the victim onto an online
dating app using her own profile picture
he then used software to create
computer-generated images of her these
images showed her naked being choked by
a police officer and being
stabbed the victim eventually obtained a
stalking protective order but the
perpetrator objected arguing that fake
the fake digital images that he was
creating and posting were a form of
expression protected by Free
Speech the New Hampshire Supreme Court
upheld the order finding that the
defendant's Behavior Uh including the
post using computer generated images of
sexual and physical violence constituted
a threat this ruling came on top of a
2015 ruling State versus Craig where the
Supreme Court ruled threatening or
harassing social media post about a
person can still count as stocking even
if the offender never directly sent them
to the
victim this sort of Behavior Uh
overwhelmingly harms women and children
and unfortunately right now it's booming
online at an unprecedented rate during
the first 9 months of
113,000 deep fake porn videos were
uploaded to the top 35 websites that
Host this sort of content that's nearly
double the number of deep fake porn
videos that were uploaded in all of the
year
before there are currently no federal
laws in the United States against the
creation and sharing of non-consensual
deep fake
pornography for a victim a deep fake
video can be a a lifelong sentence um it
might only take the creator of a video
like that a few minutes to put something
like that on the internet but once it's
up on the internet I I think I think as
we all know uh it can pretty much live
forever what this bill would do is
something that's very simple it extends
an existing New Hampshire law in a way
that ensures there are very real
consequences for the very real harm and
dis uh that this sort of Behavior Uh uh
entails and and and for the destructive
nature of it um that ruins lives uh and
reputations and with that I'll take any
questions the committee has
yeah um my question
is how how would you know if the image
you possess in other words people share
images if someone shared such an image
that they got from someone else how
would they know that it was a deep fake
or would they be subject to this or is
this only targeted at the
Creator so you're asking how how would
you know it's a deep fake image yeah how
would how would you charge someone with
with a violation of this for sharing a
deep faked image or posting it if they
got it somewhere else I mean in other
words these things come from everywhere
um I I think that there's a person from
the state police who might be able to
answer that question better than me but
um uh a lot of these videos are actually
posted on uh websites that are dedicated
for that purpose so bottom line is if if
if it's on one of these websites it's
likely to be a deep fake okay represent
re yes is there any way to trace and see
where the who made these videos is there
like an identifier to know who who
started these deep fake pictures or
whatever or is it Anonymous are they
easy to trace um another great question
for the State Police I'm I'm sure that
there are cases where they are traceable
back to the person and there are ways to
do that um I'm I'm not aware of anything
in the video itself that would uh you
know indicate who created it um and
there may be depending on
uh and and I'm kind of getting a little
bit outside my area of knowledge but
there there are metadata that typically
get created along with digital files I
know with photography files still image
files uh there's actually quite a bit of
metadata that can be recorded what I'm
less sure of is what what gets recorded
in something like an MPEG file uh a
motion picture file representative Jamon
thank you Mr chairman and thank you
representative for taking my question
um I I noticed that you're talking about
synthetic image um and in your testimony
you said video um is there a reason why
when you were drafting the bill you
didn't say video and image because they
they can be different yeah I
think there's a difference between a
video let's say that's taken of you on a
video camera and uh an image that can be
generated through I AI so for example um
you can generate um what looks like a
video of a person from from as little as
a single still image and the more still
images that you have taken from the more
taken from more angles the more
realistic that representation can be but
what it is is it's really a glorified am
uh uh animation that looks photoreal so
to you and I looking at that video we
look at it and say oh my God that's
that's a that's a video of real people
um but the reality is is that with the
use of artificial uh artificial
intelligence technology videos like that
can be put together in a way so so that
they're indistinguishable I mean another
way to think of it is it's at some point
in the future we're going to see uh
Hollywood film stars that have been dead
for 60 years like uh Humphrey Bogart and
Lauren Mcall realistically acting in new
movies I'm looking forward to that
actually um representative jamer thank
you for allowing the followup um this
would be very similar to a video I saw
about 10 years ago with Hank Williams
and Hank Williams J Jr singing uh family
tradition together um but the question I
have now is in the drafting of the bill
if I I'm going to point to um line five
of the draft here of the bill um it says
distribute twice I'm wondering if
striking the first word distribute in
that line and just leaving or otherwise
distribute would be make more sense cuz
it says distribute
twice I I I'm sorry striking which which
word um in line five yeah it says I'll
I'll read the line
electronically comment distribute sell
lease exhibit display or otherwise
distribute you distributes it twice oh
yes yeah good
catch I would probably get rid of the
first
distribute yeah represent Stone thank
you thank you and thank you for taking
my
question would this also apply to images
of politicians or any other celebrity
that's in a still shot that would be
shared on new multiple platforms that I
think images of politicians uh and
uh I think one of the things that we've
seen is we've seen over the years this
technology um can be used for other
things um and I think when it comes to
politicians there's a First Amendment
issue um around uh fair use and parity
and things things like that so um I I
think a a statute around uh prohibiting
the use of it in political campaigns
might be something that's that's needed
but it would be very complicated to
write and there there there are
potentially First Amendment landmines
all over the place um and I think this
is something that's much narrower and I
I actually have a a professional
experience from a few years back I was
uh the uh the project manager of uh of a
health app where we did uh age
progression and one of the things that
we we did was we used iOS facial
recognition um uh 2016 version which was
a lot less capable than than than what's
available now and we actually sent
images back to the University of Toronto
in a Mainframe where the an artificial
intelligence program was used to
actually age uh the app was intended for
young people let's say in their in their
20s who could take a selfie of
themselves um and then in about about 30
seconds they would see what they look
like let's say at the age of 45 if they
go into a tanning booth uh every week
you know for the next 20 years um if
they drink a certain amount of alcohol
every week for the next 20 years um sun
exposure weight gain so the idea the
idea of the app was to try to influence
behavior it called uh basically there
there's a behavioral Factor called the
temporal distancing where um uh it's
sort of the the the the uh the father
you are the father away you are from the
consequences of your behavior whether it
can be years or whatever the less likely
you are to kind of modify your behavior
so that you um you have a better outcome
down the road which is a long way of
saying that beer I can drink now feels a
lot better than worrying about that 45y
old guy 25 25 years from now who has a
big gut because he drank too much beer
I'd rather have that beer now that's
called temporal distancing so there
there are ways you can actually use this
technology in in in a way that's
extremely productive and when I was out
on the iTunes Store in addition to def
finding face swapping a apps which are
which are out there um there are also
age progression apps that work about 100
times better than the one that we did
back in 2016 so the the technology has
really really evolved and
accelerated thank you for clarification
yep represent
Newman yeah I just have a question about
line 19 which is the definition of the
synthetic image and in your testimon
you've often used Ai and it's really
realistic would this law apply would it
be a violation of the law no matter how
you made it re a realistic image that is
a false representation doesn't have to
be done by AI you've said that but I
don't know whether that that is true if
you are very skilled at a program like
like Photoshop or a non- AI program it
would and and essentially it got to the
same outcome um it would have the same
it would have the same effect under the
law which is why it's written that way
and and by the way the the definitions
were written with the help of the uh the
New Hampshire Coalition against Domestic
and Sexual
Violence thank
you see no further questions thank you
thank
you chair calls attorney
Enders
good afternoon Stephen Enders I'm an
assistant County attorney in Marat
County uh we do in fact support this
bill I think that as technology advances
you always end up in this situation
where Bad actors use that technology to
exploit people until the law eventually
catches up and what this bill does is be
proactive and sort of get ahead of that
before it occurs so we do support it and
I'm happy to answer any questions
representative
Jamon thank you Mr chairman um and thank
you for taking my question attorney
uh this bill deals with uh
non-consensual
dissemination do you believe that this
same protection should be at some point
extended to the protection of
minors because they cannot
consent this would include miners within
it as it is now if you were making um
synthetic images of miners engaged in
sexual activity that would run a foul of
the child sexual abuse images statute
which would be a a whole separate felony
thank
you represent
scitec I'm concerned that um it's a
wonderful idea of course but can this is
almost B with is Tech technology make
this almost
unenforcable because of how much can be
done and anonymity and I I don't think
necessarily technology makes it
unenforceable um certainly I think there
are ways to investigate crimes um you
know I can for example if we had a
suspect that we suspected was making um
syn synthetic images and distributing
them you could obtain a search warrant
for that suspect's computer and that
computer would show um artifacts which
would lead you to believe that perhaps
that was the computer used in the
crime follow up I guess really what I'm
saying is if one of these appears is
there any way to trace where it came
from I think it would be difficult
certainly to trace where it came from
unless you had um a
suspect
and that was my question kind of what I
was asking represent Muse is is this is
this more of a targeted at the Creator
or possessor of these images um so in
other words if someone's on a a message
board or some site and gets a picture
and sends it to his friend and say hey
look at this this hilarious and their
friend says hey that's offensive I'm
going to report that he didn't create it
so I think it's it's aimed at anyone
who's disseminating it so anyone who
passes it back and forth correct which I
think the current statute 6449 a
addresses anyone who
disseminates um non-consensual sexual
abuse images so whether that's the
person that created it or whether that's
the person who got it and is
redistributing it um the current statute
and this bill would Target both of those
individuals I guess my question or maybe
my
concern some some places some
celebrities May pose nude um and someone
may share that with someone say hey look
this is so and so Star right and it ends
up being not a real one is that person
now going to be culpable for this felony
I mean do you have to prove that they
knew it was a false image well you also
have to show that they had the intent to
harass intimidate threaten or course the
depicted person
okay okay that clears it up thank you
any further question uh representative
Balden I remember still you're a really
entertaining testimony in this committee
um the last bym on the bill to ban uh
which passed and is now a law to ban um
the non-con central sharing of digital
private images is this is this bill
essentially an expansion of that to
include images that aren't in their
original form I don't know if it's an
expansion of that bill as much as an
expansion of the the
6449 the the quote unquote revenge porn
statute the non-consensual dissemination
of private sexual images um I think the
con the concern obviously is
that you know if you if there's a
picture of you floating around that
somebody has you're frightened that they
may distribute
it the fact of the matter is that
technology exist now that that picture
of you doesn't have to exist and someone
can create it out of whole cloth and
then distribute it and this would
address that that
concern see no further questions thank
you for your
testimony is there anyone else wishing
to testify on this bill who has not
testified
yet um please come forward and when
you're finished uh give a pink card
please
oh no I think she did both thank you as
a matter of fact actually I remember it
had very neat
handwriting I'll it yeah okay thank
you good morning Mr chair members of the
committee my name is Tamara Hester I'm a
lieutenant with the New Hampshire State
Police I'm the commander of the special
investigations unit we investigate uh
child exploitation offenses as well as
conducting uh cyber crime investigations
and doing digital forensics on digital
evidence that comes in
throughout the state of New Hampshire in
terms of this particular bill um
amending this existing statute will give
law enforcement the clear ability to
enforce the sharing of material in an
online platform um the expansion of the
definition of disseminate does actually
assist in the current technological age
that we live in it's no longer necessary
to connect with individuals in person in
order to share material it's as simple
as a click of a button to generate as
well as share an image across multiple
platforms and from there the image can
be circulated around the world with the
advancement of the digital age it's
created new forms of harassment and
cyber bullying since the statute was
enacted technology has evolved currently
there are numerous software programs
available most of them free that can
generate realistic images or videos that
are virtually indistinguishable from a
real
person there have been many instances
across the country as well as ones that
I can attest to in the state of New
Hampshire of individuals utilizing
artificial intelligence to create fake
pornographic images and share them
across multiple social media platforms
many of them in a fashion which is
considered revenge porn these images can
be of both adults and children sharing
of an image that is nearly
indistinguishable from a real person and
shares the characteristics of that
person can have a crippling effect on an
individual's life and to create a
lasting stigma as is difficult to
completely remove something from the
internet once it's there defendants are
sometimes able to avoid being criminally
charged by taking images of those real
people and altering them in a computer
gener ated
fashion this creates an endless
opportunity to victimize
individuals um and I just I wanted to
address one of the questions that came
up from other one of the other
Representatives I apologize because I
don't remember who asked it about um how
to trace back once the images have been
disseminated I think the question was
answered about um the the intent of the
statute of dissemination but um if if
the victim reports and they know the
account that it comes from enforcement
can then um as as the uh County attorney
indicated we can then uh take that
account information and subsequently
conduct legal process in order to
subsequently identify that
individual thank you
questions see none thank you for your
testimony is there anyone else wishing
to testify on this bill who has not done
so seeing none I hear hereby Clos the
public hearing on House Bill what was
this 1319 1319
1319 and I open the public hearing on
House Bill
1587 good afternoon Mr chair um I'm
introducing uh this bill uh in uh in
place of Representative uh Gabby Gman
who has requested uh that we voted an
expedient to legislate um if you would
like me to I can read her uh letter to
you and the committee and to the record
sure good evening chairman Roy and
honorable me members of the criminal
justice and Public Safety Committee I
wanted to respectfully let you know that
is my intention for hb5 Dean uh 87 FN to
request an itl from the criminal justice
and Public Safety Committee on Friday
unless there is testimony that comes
forward that would demonstrate that
there is still a need after much
research and discussion with State
Police ACLU student transportation
stakeholders and vendors surveillance
vendors disability stakeholders it has
come to our attention that school buses
in New Hampshire including the big buses
and the smaller buses are not required
to have video surveillance a mandate it
was our belief that this legislation
would provide equity and safety on
special education buses when we first
put this legislation in in 2018 there
was a different need at that time the
conquered School District was still not
requiring surveillance for all their
contracts with bus providers that is no
longer the case in 2024 without a
mandate uh this is under local control
and contract negotiations for school
districts and transportation providers
both parties have ackn knowled the
importance and currently there have been
no issues reported uh and uh there's a
belief that 99% of Transportation
vendors and school districts are
requiring this already the Hudson New
Hampshire case had video surveillance on
the bus Which captured uh abuse uh the
Mandate from the state would take away
the local control that has caught up
with many public safety standards and
talking with Trooper Greg Hildreth from
the Department of Safety that handles
Pupil Transportation he also found
another direct conflict with the
wiretapping statute involving School
recordings which I've attached below
Trooper hildr has not heard of any
situations involving Pupil
Transportation that didn't have
surveillance since the smaller buses are
included under the definition of school
buses if a school requires surveillance
uh for a contract the smaller buses are
included the issue came up uh because of
minivans uh and vans and Trooper
Hildreth believes that most vendors want
this protection as do schools uh and are
using cameras for their own liability
purposes I appreciate your time and
attention to this request for an itl is
the prime sponsor it appears the issue
has already resolved itself with
technology time and local attention to
safety um see you in committee and if
you have any questions feel free to
reach out to me thank you so much Gabby
Gman
thank you
represent um since he doesn't have any
answers there won't be any questions um
anyone else wishing to testify on this
bill seeing none I'm going to close
public hearing on House Bill
1587 and the committee will stand in
recess for 30 minutes you think or do
you need more 30 30 minutes before we
begin our executive sessions um
Republicans will be meeting across the
hall
actually make it uh 45 minutes we'll be
meeting a quarter
three
e
opening the executive session
and we're starting with House Bill
1035 and I
recognize uh representative har GA right
who would you like to make a
motion representative s would you like
to make a motion I move to itl and I
second that motion would you like to
speak to your motion yes um I I think
it's a poorly written Bill and in
addition to that it would block further
cooperation between states um in
bringing criminals to Justice
well said any further
discussion seeing none I'd ask the clerk
to call the
role I
did Vice chair roads yes representative
Pratt yes representative scitec yes
representative PR yes representative
janden yes representative Manion yes
representative Reed yes representative
Stone yes representative tenar yes
representative Harry gther yes
representative Muse yes representative
Balden yes representative Bradley yes
representative Murphy yes representative
Newman yes the clerk votes yes
representative Newell yes representative
celik yes representative wheeler yay
chairman Roy chair votes yes motion is
unanimous unanimous itl any objection to
consent seeing none go on consent we
have 20 people here tonight yes thank
you yeah and I close the executive
session on 10:35 I open the executive
session on 1404 and recognize
representative janver to make a motion M
uh Mr chairman I uh move
itl thank
you would you like to speak to your
motion yes Mr chairman uh one of the
provisions in the bill uh would set the
limit for a jury trial at $20 and that
is so low that it would clog our courts
and all the court system definitely
would uh be an
injustice and would you like to speak to
your second I agree thank you further
discussion I like that I'm going to use
that seeing none ask cler to call the
role Vice chair roads yes representative
Pratt yes representative scitec yes
representative PR yes representative
janen yes representative Manion yes
representative Reed yes representative
Stone yes representative tenar yes
representative Harry Gite yes
representative Muse yes representative
Balden yes representative Bradley yes
representative Murphy yes representative
Newman yes the clerk votes yes
representative Newell yes representative
cik yes representative wheeler yay
chairman Roy chair votes yes 20 20 itl
any objection to consent see none it
will go on consent uh hereby close the
executive session on House Bill 1404 I
open the executive session House Bill
1438 and I recognize representative Reed
to make a motion my mo i motion to
itl
second um representative um Reed would
you like to speak to your motion yes um
this bill is too vague it doesn't um
specify um any laws and it would make um
anybody
um part of The Whistleblower protection
even if they aren't aware that they are
part of the program it's just too vague
and not workable in its current form
thank you who made the
second I did would you like speak to you
a second I I agree that that it um Lees
people who may not know they're in The
Whistleblower program uh offering to
help a police officer because they say
hey we're just looking for so and so if
they just say oh I'm helping the police
they're down the street they could
become a victim of a crime they could be
a criminal and I I think it's just way
too vague
and would lead to a lot of chaos thank
you um I I'm just going to add I I fully
endorse the idea of giving protection to
actual whistleblowers for their
actual fact that they are whistleblowers
but this doesn't
specify whistleblowers for the crime so
if the police said hey I'm looking for
so and so because I want to ask some
questions I think they may have killed
someone and you cooperate with the
police and they make an arrest on that
you could be charged because they were
also a whistleblower it doesn't specify
it's very vague so it's it's a dangerous
Bill vague bills are dangerous further
discussion seeing none I ask clerk to
call the role motion on the floor is
inexpedient to legislate Vice chair Roes
yes representative Pratt yes
representative citech yes representative
PR yay representative Janan yes
representative man
yes representative Reed yes
representative Stone yes representative
tenar yes representative Harry gother
yes representative Muse yes
representative Balden yes representative
Bradley yes representative Murphy yes
representative Newman yes the chair uh
the clerk votes no yes uh representative
new yes representative celik yes
representative wheeler yay chairman Roy
chals 20 20 inexpedient to legislate
anyone uh object to consent seeing none
I close the executive session on House
Bill
1455 and was 1438
1438 we're on 1455 now I open the
executive session 1455 and recognize
representative janver to make a motion
thank you Mr chair I move itl second
would you like to speak to your motion
absolutely uh one of the provisions in a
bill says no person
shall create a rule policy or protocol
is contrary to the prohibition in
paragraph one uh this flies in the face
of of the New Hampshire Constitution
coal Powers separation of powers of the
Judiciary the general court and the
executive branch and for that reason I'm
voting for itl representative Stone
would you like to speak to your second
Mr chairman I would I'd like to Simply
state that uh this bill would cause uh
conflicting jurisdiction between federal
and state law in addition on some of the
issues that were underlying in the
bill further discussion representative
sik thank you I just would also like to
emphasize that I support the itl because
I think of the risk um of people
using ways with this to get around
protective orders as well in public
settings thank you um so you know for
discussion ask clerk caller rooll Vice
chair roads yes representative Pratt yes
representative scitec representative
yes representative jenan yes
representative Manion yes representative
Reed yes representative Stone yes
representative tenar yes representative
Harriet Gite yes representative
Muse yes representative Balden yes
representative Bradley yes
representative Murphy yes representative
Newman yes the clerk votes yes
representative Newell yes representative
sik yes representative wheeler yay
chairman Ro chair votes yes 20
Z 20 Z itl any objection to consent
seeing none It will'll Go on consent I
hereby close the executive session on
House Bill 1455 I open the executive
session on House Bill
1535 and recognize uh representative
nman to make a message I me make a
message make make a
motion I make the motion to itl
Second seconded by representative
approve representative Newman would you
like speak to your motion yes just from
the testimony we heard this bill is
absolutely um overstated it it just it
could um exclude things like driver's
licenses or maybe even birth
certificates so um it deserves ideal
would you like to speak to your second
representative Pro I'm going to quote my
fellow representative over there I
agree forther
discussion representative
scitec the W the future I'm wondering if
interim study might not I'm not going to
push for it but it seems like interim
study might make more sense there is
some room for digital
inut information being used and I hate
to just say no but I'm not going to push
it either I'm just making the statement
your input is well taken and I I agree
with you however with the number of
bills we have in the short time we have
with the campaign season coming up um I
think that the the onus would have been
on the
on the uh sponsor to take that time but
I'm sure it will be back to your point
um seeing no further discussion I would
ask clerk to call the r motion of floor
itl Vice chair roads yes representative
Pratt yes representative
scitec yes representative pu you beta
representative jenan yes representative
Manion yes representative Reed yes
representative Stone yes representative
tenar yes representative Harry goth yes
yes representative Muse yes
representative Balton yes representative
Bradley yes representative Murphy yes
representative Newman yes the clerk
votes yes representative Newell yes
representative cik yes representative
wheeler y chairman Roy chair votes yes
220 20 unanimous itl any objection to
consent seeing none I hereby close the
executive session on House Bill
1535 and open the executive session on
House Bill 169 19 and recognize
representative stone for a motion Mr
chair I recommend making a motion to
itl can I get a second second second by
representative appr would you like to
speak to your motion Mr chair I would uh
the subcommittee met we uh unanimously
voted itl 4 to zero there was no one
from the public who came to speak the
sponsor was not there to speak either uh
one of the big issues that the committee
felt is that the uh language and
redefining was very conflicting and very
problematic for the entire bill with
also conflicting with other parts of New
Hampshire statutes uh this uh entire
bill was written in such a way that it's
really hard to follow and creates uh
numerous problems in addition to
operationally uh providing individuals
who are released from custody but are
still in State's custody because they
still have a pending sentence to have
firearms is not in the interest of
Public
Safety thank you um representative PR do
you agree unintended consequences
abound in this bill so we don't have
time to fix it and the sponsor didn't
seem like he wanted to fix it so I think
we should just let it go further
discussion representative s thank you I
I agree with the motion to itl I would
say however I do believe that it's too
late this session but for uh next year
for those of us who are reelected I
would love to bring forward a bill to
give the right to vote back to all
people okay representative Murray I was
going to share what representative celix
shared that I do support um giving um
incarcerated people the right to vote um
but it seems like it was unworkable in
the time we have with this bill to limit
it to just that scope thank you further
discussion seeing none asked the clerk
to call the role motion of floor is
it Vice chair Ro yes representative
Pratt yes representative
scitec representative PR yay
representative jandrin yes
representative ative Manion yes
representative Reed y representative
Stone yes representative tenar yes
representative gather yes representative
Muse yes representative Balden yes
representative Bradley yes
representative Murphy yes representative
Newman yes the clerk votes yes
representative Newell yes representative
celik yes representative wheeler yay
chairman Roy chair votes yes 20 20 itl
any objection to consent seeing none I
hearby close the executive session House
Bill 16 oh excuse me 15 I don't even
know where I am 1619 I hereby open the
executive session on here uh 1064 and I
recognize representative nle to make a
motion I make a motion to
itl Second it seconded by representative
PR would you like to speak to your
motion representative sure um this bill
uh you know I I agree with what uh the
domestic violence Coalition came and
said that this would be uh a step back
and very uh dous for domestic violence
victims and then also um the idea that
we had um people in law enforcement come
and and tell us about how um that you
know for a a temporary protective order
um it requires a clear and present
danger um and there is a due process
built into the process to um to regain
your weapon so that is why I am voting
ideal thank you representative Pro would
you like to speak to you
second I didn't second I'll second oh
I'll speak to it um because of the
testimony given by the stakeholders and
the uh State Police and different uh
professionals uh I believe in itl is the
best thinging for this thank you
discussion seeing none ask cl to call
the role motion of floor is itl vice
chair roads yes representative
Pratt representative scitec
representative pu yes representative
janen yes representative Manion yes
representative Reed yes representative
Stone yes represent restive tzar yes
representative Harry gther yes
representative Muse yes representative
Balden yes representative Bradley yes
representative Murphy yes representative
Newman yes the clerk votes yes
representative Newell yes representative
celik yes representative wheeler
chairman Roy chair votes yes 20 20 RTL
any objection to consent seeing none
here I close the executive session on
House Bill 1064 open the executive
session House Bill 107 73 and recognize
representative PR to make a motion I
move itl I'll second seconded by
representative har GA right would you
like to speak to your motion
representative Pro I would so we heard
that as the bill as the law stands right
now there are plenty of protections for
people playing jokes having
Novelties uh but there is
also which I think needs to be there
that if somebody is definitely placed
something with an intent to
cause chaos dismay
whatever to have people think that it's
a real explosive is an issue and there
needs to be protection of the public
against that because people start
running away from one of these things
people get hurt all that stuff so I
don't think we need to repeal this I
think the way the law stands
is just fine
thank you representative GA would you
like to speak to your second no I think
he did a great job good further
discussion the quot seeing Oh
representative
scitech de over about
intent
so I would add that the um the the there
was an example given of somebody who was
over zealously prosecuted or threatened
with prosecution because they had a what
was obviously a gag that's the reason we
have judges if if a officer were to
bring a a spous charge like that the
court would look would frown upon that
I'm quite sure um having said that no
further discussion I would ask cl to
call the RO motion of floor is itl oh
was somebody else wishing I just wanted
to say that did no representatives were
harmed in cus
yes Vice chair Roots yes representative
Pratt yes representative scitec yeah
representative pu absolutely
representative janr yes repres
representative Manion yes representative
Reed yes representative Stone yes
representative tenar yes representative
Harriet gther yes representative Muse
yes representative Balden yes
representative Bradley yes
representative Murphy yes representative
Newman yes the clerk votes yes
representative Newell yes representative
celik yes representative wheeler yay
chairman Roy chair votes yes 20 20 itl
any objection to consent seeing none I
hereby close the executive session house
Bill 1073 open the executive session in
House Bill 1599 recognize representative
Muse to make a motion make a motion to
itl
1599 represent Muse Muse sorry about
that doesn't even rhyme with Pratt okay
I'll get you started go ahead representa
Muse um I make a motion
to this bill can I get a second
representative Pratt I'll second to
thank you would you like to speak to
your motion represent sure uh just
because we have the ability to build
something doesn't mean we should just
because we have the ability to legalize
something doesn't mean we should uh this
bill is the uh the king of the
unintended consequences Bill bills uh
and uh I think it Ling it is definitely
the right way to go thank you would you
like to speak to your second
representative Pratt just shortly I
don't believe a AI should be used to
kill anybody uh for any reason so I
don't think this bill is necessary at
this time thank you um and so my hopes
for my own terminated robot we dashed um
May next time you can get an electronic
Koo
maybe next year there's always next year
um see up forther discussion ask cler to
call the rooll motion of the floor is
itl vice chair Roes yes representative
Pratt yes representative scitec
representative PR yay representative
Janan yes representative Manion yes
representative Reed yes representative
Stone yes representative tenar yes
representative gaite yes representative
Muse yes representative
Bolton definitely paying
attention yes representative Bradley yes
representative Murphy yes representative
Newman yes the clerk votes yes
representative Newell yes representative
suik yes representative wheeler chairman
Roy Geralds 20 20 itl any objection to
consent seeing none hereby close the
public hearing on House Bill 1599 and I
open a executive session House Bill 1237
and recognize representative Stone to
make a motion Mr chair I make a motion
to itl um second seconded when we open
the discussion can bring it up um
somebody else wants to no um someone had
asked to introduce an amendment well
let's have the discussion on the motion
on the floor first um representative
Stone would you like to speak to your
motion Mr chairman I would uh this bill
is discriminatory in nature for
municipalities it impedes on local
control uh it's not in the interest of
Public Safety and it seems to exclude
the largest agency that uses ghost cars
in the state of New
Hampshire representative BR would you
like to speak to you a
second I will but you won't like it
um to me this
was put in by somebody who just doesn't
want to get a speeding ticket so I would
suggest you buy a radar detector instead
of putting in a bill like this
um because we use the police use those
vehicles to patrol for people who are
driving reckless and protect Public
Safety and if we don't have that Tool uh
they can't do their job quite as well
all righty um representative Murray
would you like to speak on discussion
thank you Mr chair I just wanted to let
members of the committee know that I've
given you each a copy of an amendment
that I submitted to OS that narrows the
scope of the bill um ensures that uh any
Vehicles purchased on or after January
1st 2025 would be marked and labeled
identifying it as a police vehicle um
and that would only be applicable to
those explicitly performing traffic law
enforcement and any officer who is in an
unmarked vehicle and observes um an
offens of reckless driving uh potential
DUI or or any other threat to Public
Safety would still be able to make a
traffic stop um under this
amendment so should the motion on the fa
floor fail uh represent Murray tends to
offer this amendment um
discussion representative um sing first
and bden thank you um so I think that
I'm very conflicted on the bill I I
appreciate the intent of the person who
wrote it and hope that they will work
with law enforcement
agencies um to bring something better
back next year um I think one of the
things that's really complicated is
especially in small towns there are
often very few vehicles and they may be
used for all sorts of purposes where it
may not be practicable for them to have
one designated specifically to traffic
enforcement and others for various
undercover operations and sorts of
things and so to me it feels like
there's too many complexities that are
not resolved and as much as I appreciate
the intent and think it should actually
apply to State Vehicles as well um it
there's too much there there aren't
enough
nuances on the topic of Public Safety
one time I was paying attention I
remember that we received testimony from
a trooper who said that the presence of
marked police vehicles has a positive
effect on driver behavior um a
demonstrably positive effect and I think
I'd rather have fewer people dying in
car accidents in our state than more
tickets thank you I believe he said
there was a study that showed they
actually had numbers I don't know what
they were representative
Murray thank you Mr chair I just forgot
to know as I had sent to the committee
the other states that have um similar
laws in place California DC Idaho
Montana New Mexico Ohio Oklahoma and
South Carolina all requireed that
vehicle uh police Les always be marked
um and then states that have uh laws
similar to the amendment I'm I hope to
present are Connecticut Georgia Michigan
New Jersey New York North Carolina
Oregon Pennsylvania Washington and
Wyoming um so just to name that um that
we wouldn't be the first by any means
many states have similar
laws definitely further discussion
representative
PR representative Sy I must have missed
his intent so what was the intent of the
bill that you perceived because I
perceived that he was looking to get out
of speeding tickets and red light
tickets by unmarking by marking police
cars I don't recall um if he did say his
intent but represent thank you I I
interpreted his bill to to mean that he
wanted to prevent situations like the
one where representative new was in
where people who were in plane clothes
and not in marked Vehicles were um
potentially stopping people and and the
difficulty with
identifying um police in certain
circumstances and having been in similar
circumstances myself um I I recognize
the terror of having someone having
flashing lights behind you and not being
able to determine whether or not they
are in fact police in the days before
there were cell phones because I'm you
know old enough for for that I will say
um as a former resident of Maryland um
the state police there often took uh no
longer usable um state trooper vehicles
and slice them in half and put the half
on different parts of the highway system
so people would drive up and it would
appear there was a State Trooper there
um just something to keep in mind and
all the traffic would go from 95 miles
an hour down to like 55 very quickly in
those sections um and then you know
you'd get past it and realize the other
side was a wood frame I would add that
if someone were to bring a bill and they
were to actually do a study and and show
how many people were stopped by unmarked
vehicles and and to and if it were
adversely impacting the public versus
how many vehicles how many accidents it
saved I'd like to see numbers more than
just you know I don't like the idea of
of sneaky cars represent man thank you
Mr chair so a couple things here the the
first thing I want everyone to
understand is is unmarked vehicles are
not the same as ghost Vehicles ghost
vehicles are marked Vehicles they're
just subtle and actually they're more
visible at night than a marked as you
would say police car uh some of marked
police cars aren't don't have reflective
lettering on it but it's they different
color so you can clearly see it during
the day but at night these ghost cars
are more visible they're fully marked
it's just a more subtle subdued marking
on the side uh people that are operating
those are in uniform generally so the
issue I have um with that is the
unmarked Vehicles where it's a plain
closed person they're not not really
doing traffic enforcement and if you
want to make a a bill that says if
you're going to do traffic enfor you
must be in full uniform that I could
accept uh to alleviate that however by
today's in today there's cell phones you
you're allowed to drive to the police
station slowly obey the laws call
dispatch you can't get any trouble for
that because for that reason um another
thing is we're we're we're micromanaging
as a state legislature our local police
Chiefs they should have the authority to
operate their Department as they see fit
whatever Vehicles they see they they
deem to be most useful we should should
allow them to use them on the on the uh
comment about Vehicles marked Vehicles
being uh deterring crime War that's
that's true however if your department
has one ghost vehicle they use
specifically for DWI patrols and traffic
enforcement patrols it has a purpose and
to take that tool away from our local
police and tell our police Chiefs you
can't decide what's best for your
community we will I think it's wrong I
think we should leave it up to local
control I don't think we should be
taking away this option for them to use
them um that's that's where I'm at with
it that's a brings up a good point and
if anyone can tell me I'd be happy to
hear it do we
prohibit towns from voting as to what
they want to use for police
vehicles if you can answer yeah well Mr
chairman because there's no because
we're at dyan's rule state there's no
RSA on the books that says that they can
do that they cannot so there there is
not an ability for a local municipality
to go out and and ban that until law
that describes what police vehicles have
to look like I don't know the answer to
that question if there isn't one then
they can but wouldn't there have to be
and sorry for the conversation wouldn't
there have to be um uh I mean as far as
I understand for in order for a
municipality to pass a law there has to
be a law on the books that says they can
well they're allowed to with their
budget because I know I just had to
approve a new Cruiser for our town on
the budget committee so my question is
is do we can they say we're going to go
with Fords you know CR vict versus you
know whatever we're going to go with
Explorers so if they can pick what kind
of vehicle they want um are not are they
not allowed to say locally all our
police cars have to be marked with
through an ordinance we're about to make
that law telling Towns how the C's going
to look no no no I'm saying are the
towns not able to make that law if they
so choose back to your point with local
control could the voters of a town not
go to their Town Council and say hey we
want all of our Cruisers in this town to
be marked we don't want unmarked
Cruisers yeah through a warrant article
I don't but because we a Dylan's real
State I don't know if they're able to do
that though actually uh Mr chairman
that's under the the selectman's or the
the board if it's a BAL or Alderman have
the ability to um dictate policy on
purchases of the town and uh they
control Town property which the police
cruisers would be and it would be up to
that board to determine what the police
cars should look like they are allowed
under that statute oh to control Town
property what it looks like and such
since we don't have a statute to your
point that describes what all police
cars have to look like therefore they
can control Town property however they
want so to my original point I believe
that if voters in a town hated getting
caught by an unmarked car they could all
go to town hall say we want a war
article no more of that um all we could
control is our friends at the State
Police um and I I I have grave concerns
over over what that might do to our
highway safety representative
Balden that's the thing right is that if
part of what informs this conversation
is data that even we and the legislature
don't have as to the impact of a marked
versus a marked vehicle on driver
Behavior and the propensity for M
committing traffic violations how is any
given small municipality expected to
obtain that information and make an
informed decision and as much as um
local control is a phrase that sounds
nice there have been issues in the past
that really aren't workable for local
control for example gun laws if you're
traveling from like Dairy to Milford how
many laws are you going to break in the
interim with uh you know gun in your
vehicle so we can't just worship at the
altar of local control there are some
things that need to be dictated at the
state level I think that's why this
building's here true and I appreciate
your passion however a local a local
police department um doesn't really the
the data they going to have is in their
Police Department because they're not
they're they're just covering their
their town so they know how many
accidents they have they know the
statistics of how many Speeders they
pull over for the State Police is much
more difficult to your point because we
don't know how many tens of thousands of
vehicles travel over the state highways
but I would assume most towns can pull
that information readly pretty quickly
as far as how many stops the traffic the
dangers of stuff um so if if a local
Town decides that they don't want this
they can they are free to do it um but
more importantly are you changing your
position because that's an initial you
said that you didn't really favor the
bill now you kind of just made a defense
he did can we climb out of the rabbit
hole now need more Cofe I don't even
know I feel like I'm talking to The
Madhatter I don't know very good um uh
wait a minute representative Stone hold
on thank you I'd like to remind
everybody that we also have towns and
cities in New Hampshire and the current
case of clamont we have a police
commission that is in charge of the
police department and budget is in
charge of the city council
therefore the city police commission
dictates what goes on for markings
policies and procedures and I as many of
you aware most departments have policies
involving the use of how they use
unmarked vehicles for traffic
enforcement so that's something that is
uh highly scrutinized by the individual
agencies across the state of New
Hampshire and who's next representative
Newman's had his hand
for I have more of a parliamentary
question what we have a we have a motion
on the floor of itl yeah so then what is
our next vote I mean I we're having
discussion on that okay so we will have
an itl so in that case we will never get
to vote on the amendment well if the itl
fails she can induce her Amendment so
she's trying to convince people to vote
against the itl so that she can induce
her yeah I I thought it might be order
more in the or I thought that the
Motions might be in more of the order
that we see in when we go to session
where they where Mo a committee vote
they bring up a committee Amendment if
if one approves but whatever if that's
what it is that's what it is yeah okay
um represent
jamr thank you Mr chairman one of the
things that we had discussed um or I
remember being discussed was article 28a
and I'm going to read it State shall not
mandate or assign any new expanded or
modified programs or responsibilities to
any political subdivision in such a way
as to necessitate additional local
expenditure by the political subdivision
unless such programs or responsibilities
are fully funded by the state dot dot
dot so if if we're going to tell these
local departments what they must be
using we are mandating a responsibility
and it would have a cost which would be
born by the
state okay um final comments
representative first representative
Ro thank you Mr chairman so on the same
on the same side if if you're if you're
saying
that if a car is marked you're going to
slow down because you don't want to get
a ticket the same thing could be said if
you know that the cars aren't marked and
any one of them could be a cop at any
time that equally should slow you down
and I recognize that maybe I use the
speed limit as a suggestion and that's
you know when I get pulled over I have
the answer to that um but if I know that
the town's have cars that aren't marked
I I usually let off a little bit so it
could go either way however you want to
make the argument it's not going to
change your behavior unless you want to
change your
behavior representative here gather yes
I just want to make the point that it's
it's not all vehicles it's nothing in
the section should be construed to
prohibit the use of unmarked vehicles or
vehicles with steal of or ghostling for
any purpose other than traffic law
enforcement
so this is specific it is but to an
earlier Point many towns don't have more
than two cars and you're cutting their
Fleet in half if you say they can't use
it for that um only people who haven't
spoken representative Reed thank you Mr
chairman let's look at it this way I
mean obviously there's people who don't
want to get pulled over and don't want
to be surprised by the police however
think of it as you have somebody that
you love on the road the police are an
extra set of eyes we are public safety
criminal justice and Public Safety thank
you for I think that we need to also
it's an extra set of eyes watching
somebody you love drive and I will
always vote in favor of whatever that
takes to keep the people I love safe on
the road thank you anyone else who
hasn't spoken wish to
comment okay I think um we can continue
this debate on the elevator and the way
down I'd ask to call the role the
motional floor is inexpedient to
legislate
Vice chair roads that's easy yes
representative Pratt yes representative
scitech representative PR oh God yes
representative janen yes representative
Manion I wasn't paying attention yes
representative Reed yes representative
Stone yes representative tenai yes
representative gather no representative
muse no representative golden no
representative Bradley no representative
Murphy yes representative Newman no
representative oh the clerk votes no
representative Newell no representative
selik regretfully yes representative
wheeler nay uh chairman Roy chair votes
yes uh 128 128 um motion of itl carries
uh it will not be on consent um let me
see who who would like to make the um
against or the
um majority report is representative
Stone actually who made the motion on
that you did okay um would you like to
write the okay so it's going to be
representative um Alexandra Murray
writes The Minority Report and stone
writes the top one Mr chairman 128 128
if I could just have a clarification I
got a little ahead of myself the bill
that we just exacted was 12 37 yes and
the vote is 12 to8 yes thank you with
that I close the executive session on
House Bill 1237 open the executive
session House Bill 1238 recognize
representative Manion to make a motion
thank you Mr chair I Rec I need a second
second second
I who's doing what I'm sorry rep I
didn't even make my motion was
it I can undo
everything second representative Stone
second did that
yeah we
did
yeah okay go
ahead I motion itl yeah
that this is why I don't I'm not an
Auctioneer represent Stone second would
you like to speak to your motion yes I
would so this is similar to the last
bill we had however this it's talking
about just Municipal Police plates which
are pretty identifiable uh the concern I
have with this is if every vehicle that
the police Department of the Town owns
has to have these on it uh there are a
lot of detect detective vehicles um
sometimes they Vans or buses we use a
lot of different vehicles for
surveillance undercovered drug work uh
child trafficking work where you don't
want to be identified so this would
pretty much give the police up everywh
they're doing this so I don't think it's
it's it's prudent to have every vehicle
mock with these plates representative
Stone would you like to speak to a
second uh Mr chairman I would currently
I'm aware of at least uh three
variations of plates that can be
utilized on Municipal police vehicles
and uh one of the other issues that uh
unmarked vehicles used for in addition
to traffic enforcement is also uh if
there's a bank robbery that looks like
it's going to go down and they staking
out a certain location you do not want
to have uh you know government plates or
Municipal Police plates on it as it's
sitting outside a bank or or you know
maybe a liquor store thank you um does
anyone know if this bill was this did
this one already also ex exempt the
state police or was this all vehicles
Municipal so this just targeted
Municipal again yeah yeah that's not
right okay um I would just to start the
discussion and make one point you don't
need to discuss I'm sorry I just wanted
to make this point that most people when
you're getting pulled over you cannot
see the police car's plates he's usually
right up against your bumper um you see
lights in your thing you you the plate
things once the cruiser part's gone now
the plates really naturally follow any
further discussion see N US cler call
the roll
Vice chair roads yes representative
Pratt yes representative scitec
representative pu yay representative
janen yes representative Manion yes
representative Reed yes representative
Stone yes representative tzar yes
representative harri ather yes
representative Muse yes representative
bden yes representative Bradley yes
representative Murphy yes representative
Newman yes the clerk votes yes
representative Newell yes representative
suik yes representative wheeler chairman
Roy 20 20 motion of itl any objection
consent seeing none close the executive
session on House Bill 1238 and open the
executive session on House Bill 1022
recognize representative here at GAO to
make a motion a motion to ought to pass
on each be where am
I wait a minute wow wait a minute wait
wait wait
I don't think that's sorry I'm sorry oh
my God would you like to would draw that
motion yes I withraw that motion oh my
goodness and make another motion yes I
motion to itl a
second 1022 repres wheeler oh wow that's
that would would you like to speak to
your motion yes I will um we looked at
this as being unintended consequences
again taking their eyes off those who
were trafficed versus those that are
willing
participants um we solely we are solely
against legalizing sex work in any form
according to authors and researchers
poic Weiss and Mal legalized
prostitution will inadvertently force
sex work further into the shadows and
expose children to
exploitation in fact one of the most
concerning side effects of legalization
of prostitution is the potential for
human trafficking crimes to become
easier for perpetrators to commit
against children no child should be
subject to sex work life in their home
or anywhere some would say we are the
product of teachings of our
environment so we urge you to prevent
the influx of human trafficking in the
New Hampshire communities protect our
childrens and traffic the community by
opposing this bill and actually this was
something that I wrote a couple years
ago for the same
bill
no
than you like speak to your second
representative wheeler just really
quickly Mr chairman I just want to Echo
what representative goth says I have a
very large concern about proliferation
of human trafficking in this world and I
don't want to do anything that uh allows
that prolation to continue thank you uh
I would also add that even if the human
trafficking were not an issue which it
is and it's horrific if that was
something we were going to contemplate
it wouldn't be we the sponsor said well
look at Nevada look at Utah well they've
could this whole huge infrastructure
around that industry you can't just say
legal Go I mean the bill was just tossed
out I mean if he was serious about this
he would have done research he would
have had all kinds of studies there was
nothing representative uh Murray thank
you Mr chair um I will be supporting the
itl motion today um but I did want to
say I do in general support
decriminalizing sex work but I spoke to
sex workers in the community who said
they weren't reached out to by the
sponsor and did not support this
legislation as written and I think
you're correct that if we did want to do
that in the future it needs to be done
carefully in a way that allows for there
to be more regulation that increases
safety rather than decreasing um safety
I agree if it were turned out the way it
is we'd end up having you know um what's
the word pimps I mean no one's out there
protecting the women there's nothing it
would just be it'd be a mess um further
discussion representative sing I just
wanted to say I agree 100% with
representative Murray and their
reasoning and
representative Manion said that he would
like to get the contacts for the people
you spoke to
um I I would um ask the clerk to call
the
role that's fake news Vice chair
roads yes representative Pratt
yes representative Pratt Pratt yes he
says yes representative
scitech well
yeah representative PR oh you bet you
representative jandrin in the interest
of keeping Hampton Beach of family beach
yes representative minion
yes representative Reed yes
representative Stone yes representative
tenar yes representative Harry
C that's you oh yeah yes yes yes
representative Muse yes representative
Balden yes representative Bradley yes
representative Murphy yes representative
Newman yes the clerk votes yes
representative Newell yes representative
sink yes and I'm wondering if the air in
the room has been
changed representative wheeler tired
drunk chairman Roy chair votes yes
20 20 itl um any objection consent no
objection consent I hereby close the
executive session on House Bill
1022 and I open the executive session on
House Bill
1587 and I make a motion of inexpedient
to legislate second by representative
here gaite um this we are this was the
last one where the sponsor um requested
that we um itl the bill and that's
basically all the discussion anyone else
want to add
anything it it had to do with um putting
recording devices on school buses for
special ed and she said that she had
worked with uh a lot of the stakeholders
and it's already being done so she felt
that it wasn't necessary at this time
the motion I made the motion
who yeah and with that we'll call the
RO r Road yes representative Pratt yes
representative scitec representative PU
yay representative jenin yes
representative Manion yes representative
Reed yes representative Stone yes
representative tzar yes representative
gather yes representative
Muse yes representative Balon yes
representative Bradley yes
representative Murphy yes representative
Newman yes the clerk votes yes
representative Newell yes representative
sik representative wheeler yay chairman
Roy ch ch 20 20 it L any objection
consent seeing none I hear by close the
executive session House Bill 1587 um two
couple quick housekeeping things before
we leave House Bill 1366 and 1448 we I
think we all agreed that there was they
were worth amending and we were waiting
for amendments but no one's really sure
what happened to them so we're going to
figure it out and we'll take these up
next week for executive session um
everyone who has reports to this the
Speaker of the House instructed me and
the clerk told me that I'm supposed to
make people stay here until their
reports are done
having said that um everyone go home
don't make me look bad get me those
reports by Monday please um and
representative um uh representative Ro
wishes to Mr chair um I was notified
this morning that uh you guys should all
join me and wishing representative tenar
a happy
birthday can we sing a
song yeah I I apologize I didn't do it
earlier it was a long day I'll take the
contacts from Dennis
yeah very good um remember like I said
if you made a motion you ow you owe a
report or if you are writing a Minority
Report um by Monday close the business
please thank you have a good weekend
chairman Roy is it appropriate to write
this is just a bad Bill no not so much
but you could spell it out by putting
words together and making a
code